70 80%
Alo.
>> Ờ ờ Khoa nói đi.
Bây giờ thì hiện tại khoảng 70 80% của
em đang sử dụng của second brand à bộ
nhớ đó. Và bây giờ được nó được một cái
một cái sướng đó là mình có thể mình kết
nối được nhiều cái cái cái con action
với nhau và xong mình làm mình phát
triển và xong đó là nó được có một cái
hay cái là nó hoàn toàn local nha. Dữ
liệu nó không bị thất thoát. Ừ. Đó là
một trong những cái mà
em thấy cực kỳ hay, thú vị mà nói chung
là bây giờ là có thể xài bất kỳ con nào
cũng được. Từ anti
em đang xài con mới xài thêm
>> hả?
>> Ừ con con clot đúng không? trước á
>> xài nhiều lắm anh
xài clock open cloud
xài cả
con
>> xài cả con han
kêu trực tiếp mà kêu giá tiếp kém
>> ok ta
>> không có tại vì có anh em chưa quên nói
>> à thế xài thêm những cái con a con a mới
sáng này mới em mới mua thêm một cái
Con clan nó sử dụng được những cái
open á xài đã lắm anh.
Con G con con gì? Con GLM hay là con GLM
5.2 hay là con gì? Hay là con mới?
>> Không cái con Cly là nó gom chung lại nó
xài hết tất cả những cái con
>> à biết rồi. Hình như là giá của nó là 10
10 đô 9.99 đô con Cly nè.
>> Đúng rồi.
>> À ok.
Nó mới nó mới mở sáng nay ch mấy đâu anh
>> à. Tính ra qua cũng đầu tư dữ ha. Để
share luôn cho anh em cái con này. Ừ.
>> Con này đúng không? Con Cly.
>> Đó đó. Em mới mua sáng tức thi nè.
>> À tính ra là qua đầu tư cũng dữ ha.
>> Đó mua không nó cái giá này nè cái giá
này là 9 đô 9 là 10 đô. Nhưng mà tháng
đầu tiên á là anh nó chỉ có giá 5 đô
thôi để nó có IPI. Còn nếu mà anh sử
dụng anh anh sử dụng COI á thì nó có 1.2
đô à.
>> Ừ.
>> Mới mua sáng này
>> sáng là 5 đô hả? Là là đang đang ấy là 5
đô.
>> Đang 5 đô. Đang đang 5 đô.
>> Ừ. Cho tháng đầu á.
>> Tháng đầu.
>> Ừ. Ừ. Ờ
>> bữa giờ
anh nói
>> cái mô hình này là nó cho mình lấy IP
không ta? Cái mô hình cái con line này
cho lấy IP không?
>> Có. Nó có lấy IP để mình nhét vô
>> miễn phí không? Miễn phí không?
>> Thì nó tính vô trong cái gói sub nó thôi
chứ miễn phí gì anh. À tính vô gói sub
này luôn hả?
>> Đúng rồi. Một sub nó xài cũng ok đó
nhưng mà mồi sáng xài thấy cũng ổn quá
anh. Nhưng mà hôm bữa giờ cộng đồng đang
nói về cái con J 5.2 dữ quá.
>> Đúng rồi. Con
>> xài mà xài cũng xuống thiệt. Hôm bữa giờ
xài thích lắm.
Em a em a em bỏ vô con home con homet á.
Wow cày cày nát luôn.
>> Ừ con đó nó hiện nay giá con đó của
Trung Quốc n giái khá là rẻ cực rẻ. Rẻ
hơn các model khác mà tính ra model thì
cũng tương tự na ná cỡ cỡ xem xem với
con 5 chấm mấy nghe được khen với con
5.5 của con kia luôn mà.
>> [hắng giọng]
>> 5.5 thì cái mô hình của nó là nó ổn, nó
tốt mà mới thằng mới hồi sáng á thằng
Hate á nó ra thêm một cái cái MO á anh.
>> Ừ. Nghĩa là nó phối nó phối lên cái mô
hình nó phối lại nhiều cái mô hình với
nhau. Xong rồi nó tạo ra một cái gọi là
cái mô hình tốt hơn cả Oppus 4. Ừ 4.7
4.8 luôn
>> trên Hernet Agent hả?
>> Đúng rồi anh.
>> À
>> nó nó thêm một cái cái đó nữa đang ứng
dụng cũng khá là hay và thú vị.
>> Ừ [hắng giọng]
>> ừ ừ. Cái conet Asian đó mình cũng đang
nghiên cứu để mình thấy nó hay quá. Cái
con đó làm trợ lý đúng bài luôn á.
>> Đúng rồi.
>> Ừ. Ừ. Ok. Bây giờ là cũng đã gần 8:6. Đã
8:6 rồi. Thôi anh em vào chắc bây giờ
xin phép nếu mà anh em nào vào sau thì
mình nhận thông tin sau và có thể là xem
lại record. Còn bây giờ thì chắc không
để anh em phải đợi lâu nữa. Còn sau cái
khoảng thời gian chia sẻ của
của Khoa nếu anh em nào có thêm câu hỏi
thì mình sẽ trao đổi thêm. Ok không anh
em?
Thì à chắc là mình chuẩn bị bắt đầu thô
Khoa hả?
>> Dạ
>> thì anh anh xin phép giới thiệu tí xíu
về mình với lại Khoa tí xíu để cho cả
nhà cùng biết rồi sau đó mình bước vào
chương trình luôn nha cả nhà. À rất là
vui à tối hôm nay được gọi là đón tiếp
anh em trong cái buổi gọi là đột xuất
chứ cũng không có thông báo trước. Thật
sự luôn. Hồi nãy có anh a anh Hải Trình
là cũng a khá vui vui á là có nói mình
sau cái buổi như thế này quá hay luôn mà
kiểu như vậy mà lại không thông báo
trước cho anh em mà lại thông báo hơi
độc xúc hơi đường đột thì cũng rất mong
anh em thông cảm vì cái buổi vừa thời
gian vừa qua mình đang đang đi chơi tí
xíu nên mình không còn thời gian nữa và
và mình còn những cái công chuyện khác
lại cũng không có chuẩn bị trước chủ đáo
nên cũng rất mong anh em thông cảm rồi
thì mình cũng xin tự giới thiệu mình là
Minh ha chắc có lẽ anh em ở trên các
cộng đồng các vị đàn hoặc là đâu đó trên
các hội nhóm thì chắc cũng biết mình
trong khoảng thời gian vừa qua mình cũng
chuyên làm về các AI A hay là chia sẻ về
AI rồi ngoài ra có một cái sở thích nữa
là giao lưu với các anh em nên nếu mà
anh em nào sau khi mà cái buổi Zoom này
kết thúc có thể kết nối với nhau qua
Zalo, qua Facebook, qua fanpage các kiểu
thì mình tiếp tục mình giao lưu và có
thể là Zoom ở các sự kiện khác. Rồi thì
ngoài ra người chia sẻ mà mình mời được
hôm nay á là anh Khoa. À thì bạn Khoa là
một trong những người bạn cũng là người
anh em của mình ở trong cộng đồng mà
mình cũng kết nối được cũng khoảng một
thời gian khá lâu kể từ cái ngày mà mình
lập ra một cái group Zalo nhỏ nhỏ thôi
là vai Working. Tuy nhiên á là Khoa vào
cũng chia sẻ rất là nhiệt tình. Thì
trong cái thời gian vừa rồi á, Khoa có
làm về ứng dụng AI nhưng mà ở đây không
phải là chỉ giống như mình mà mà hay
chia sẻ mà mọi người thấy mà ở đây là
ứng dụng những cái second rin hay là
những cái mà hôm nay anh Khoa sẽ chia sẻ
với mọi người cách ứng dụng làm sao cho
nó hiệu quả chứ không phải là những cái
thông tin tức rồi những cái trang web mà
mình thấy à nó hay xong đó mình lấy về
mình lưu trữ lúc thì notebook mm lúc thì
chỗ này chỗ kia thì trở thành dạng là
rác thông tin đó mọi người thì lúc này
Khoa sẽ có một cái cách à dùng rất là
hay ha. Và hôm nay mình sẽ được à Khoa
gọi là demo cho anh em luôn và hướng dẫn
cho anh em cách sử dụng công cụ. Ok. Rồi
cảm ơn Khoa và cảm ơn cả nhà. Xin mời
Khoa ha.
>> Dạ. Ờ dạ cảm ơn anh a mình rất là nhiều
à đã cho em có điều kiện đến buổi hôm
nay để gọi là để giao lưu với cả nhà ha.
gọi là được chia sẻ niềm đam mê về ai dạ
thì cũng m hai anh em cũng mới kết nối
gọi là cũng mới trao đổi trong tuần tư
trước thì anh Minh cũng có chia sẻ là à
muốn Kho chia sẻ về một cái
một cái vấn đề về mà Khoa thích nhất Kho
tâm đắc nhất thì nói thật với cả nhà á
là vừa nghe cái đó nói thôi hay là để em
chia sẻ về à
bộ nhớ đi, bộ nhớ đi, bộ nhớ của Asian
đi. Tên thực ngữ của nó là Second Brand.
Thì thực sự á cũng chia sẻ với cả nhà là
như thế này. Ờ Khoa cũng kho không phải
là một chuyên gia, cũng không phải là
một người gì gớm cả. Kho là một người là
chuyên về gọi là yêu thích về AI A, AI,
Lom. Và xong đó rồi mình
đam mê và mình kết nối. Xong đó mình sử
dụng nó vào trong công việc của mình. Và
mình cảm thấy khi mà mình ứng dụng
second brand á bộ nhớ agent á vào trong
công việc của mình mình cảm thấy rất là
tuyệt vời. Xong mình nói với anh Minh là
thay đy để em chia sẻ về cái này đi. Ờ
nếu mà cái này mà mình ứng dụng được á
thì nó rất là tuyệt vời luôn anh. Thế
thì nên đó là có lý do của cái buổi hôm
nay.
Nên những cũng chia sẻ với các bạn là
kho cũng không phải là sơ gì cả, cũng là
coi như là trao đổi thảo luận với nhau
thôi ha. Nên co nếu mà có những cái vấn
đề nào mà Kho chia sẻ mà nó không ok lắm
thì các bạn bỏ qua giùm mình được không
ạ?
>> Ok anh em rất là nhiệt tình luôn. Khoa
cứ yên tâm [tiếng cười] mà chia sẻ đi.
>> Dạ ok.
>> Cho xin một vàng pháo gì đó trái tim đi
cả nhà để cho truyền độc lực cho khoa
hành tí. [tiếng cười]
Rồi cảm ơn cả nhà.
>> Chia sẻ với cả nhà là để cũng là khi để
chuẩn bị cho buổi hôm nay á là kho cả
kho 4:00 sáng hôm qua dậy để chia sẻ
không biết là ok cha rồi mình mình sẽ
chia sẻ gì đây ta. Rồi liệu mọi người có
nghe có
vấn đề gì hay không hay là như thế nào
thì cũng không kết nối ra được vài cái
để mình để nói chuyện với cả nhà ngày
hôm nay.
Đầu tiên thì về cái bộ nhớ thứ hai
second brand là cái gì và tại sao mình
ứng dụng nó vào trong anti như thế nào
và những cái con agent khác như thế nào
ha. Thì chủ yếu của second trend đó là
được cái tính hay quên của
các mô hình Lom. Và cái thứ hai nữa của
nó mà mình thấy nó rất là giá trị nằm
cái chỗ gọi là chống được hallucation
nghĩa là bị đặt hả các bạn mấy nếu mà ai
nếu mà các bạn xài á thì cái con cái con
ai nào cũng vậy là nếu mà nó nó càng
càng nó càng thông minh nha nó càng
thông minh chừng nào nó bị đặt càng càng
giữ chừng nó và đôi khi mà nếu mà mình
nghe nó mà mình không kiểm chứng lại là
chết ha nên cái đó là một trong những
cái mà khi mà kho làm một cái dự án hay
là kho vi cting ở trong mấy cái dự án
của mình á thì cái đó là điều mà kho sợ
nhất ha. Thì đó là một trong những cái
mà cái bộ não thứ hai cái second brand
đã giúp cho kho rất là nhiều trong công
việc này ha. Rồi thì
ủa thế
[hắng giọng] rồi cả nhà thấy bản trình
chiếu không ạ?
>> À thấy khoan. Dạ thì kiểu kiểu mà nó hay
quên và bị đặt ha thì mình thấy nó giải
quyết được triệt để những cái vấn đề này
và những điều mà mình mình thấy nó rất
là hay ha. Rồi ờ và từ cái ý tưởng cốc
lõi là cái Wikipedia để nó xây dựng lên
bằng những cái file M down ha. nói với
các bạn hơi trừ tượng một tí xíu thì bây
giờ kho sẽ có một cái my map này để chia
sẻ cho cả nhà để cho cả nhà dễ hiểu hơn.
>> Rồi ok rồi cả nhà thấy rồi đúng không ạ?
Thấy cái này đúng không ạ?
>> Chưa thấy cái máy mép Khoai
>> chưa thấy hả? Ủa em sang mà ta
>> mới thấy cái slide thôi.
>> Bây giờ em sẽ chia sẻ cái này rồi. Ok cả
nhà mình thấy chưa? Ok
>> rồi. Ok thôi ha. Thì cái bộ nhớ AI nó
nằm ở chỗ nào và tại sao nó có có nó nó
phải có cái nguồn gốc của các bạn. Nó là
bắt đầu từ cái
xếp này nè để
cho đây nó bắt đầu từ cái sếp này nè cả
nhà. Đó là ông Kati.
Đó màu
đen đi cho nó dễ thấy ha. Bắt đầu từ
Android
Khi
ha. Ông này nè các ông này nè cả nhà.
Thì cái second brand thì nó cũng mới đây
thôi cả nhà. Nó bắt đầu từ tháng tư khi
mà bắt đầu là Kati ổng chia sẻ lên trên
một cái đoạn ha. ổng chia sẻ một cái
đoạn trick là
này để mình chia mình mình lấy cho các
bạn xem
đây cái đoạn trích của ổng ổng
đây
là ai
đây ông tên là Andre Cavat ổng là đồng
sáng lập của Open AI là một cái vấn đề
thứ hai của ổng đó là ổng hiện tại là à
ờ
mà nghĩa ổng là người nghĩa là đồng sáng
lập của Open AI. Xong rồi các bạn biết
Crock AI đúng không ạ? Cross AI đúng
không? Thì ổng là trưởng trưởng nhóm
nghiên cứu của CR AI và bây giờ á là
hiện tại ổng đang chuyển sang
bên công ty CL. Nói chung là ổng là một
người khá là ảnh hưởng ở trong cái cái
giới AI này ha. Thì tháng tư ổng ổng mới
chia sẻ ra một mô hình gọi là ờ đây LM
no List Bay à đây cái Kho sẽ để Kho chia
sẻ cái trick này cho các bạn xem luôn
ha.
Xare
đây cái tri này các bạn. Cái trick này
là mới tháng a
ờ ngày 3 tháng 04 2,1 2,1 triệu người.
Và cái này nè các bạn thấy ổng chia sẻ
một cách rất là đơn giản vậy ha. ổng
chia sẻ về mô hình Lom nhưng mà khi mà
ổng chia sẻ như thế này nè các bạn và
các anh chị rất là nhiều công ty đặc
biệt là Google nó ảnh hưởng rất là nhiều
bởi vì trước giờ các bạn anh chị thì à
cái mô hình mà để cho EN có thể nhớ á
thì người ta sẽ sử dụng một cái mô hình
gọi là mô hình factor factor các bạn để
database để kch nó thẳng vào trong cái
cho con agent đã nhớ nhưng mà ổng Capti
ổng chia sẻ rằng là thực sự không cần
phức tạp như vậy đâu chị chị chỉ cần là
một cái xây dựng cho mình một cái
Wikimedia đơn giản thôi. Rồi sau đó kết
nối vào trong con agent và con agent nó
sẽ tự đi tìm theo cái Wikimedia nó học
và bắt đầu nó chia sẻ nó hiểu được cái
cái kiến thức mà mình mình muốn chia sẻ
là cái gì ha. Rồi thì từ những cái kiến
thức mà ổng chia sẻ này á thì Kho bắt
đầu là Kho
Kho đưa ra kho K kho kho xây dựng một
cái a
cái công cụ
đó là second brand. Tất nhiên không phải
một mình xin không phải là một mình mình
xây nha các bạn. Hin ở trên thế giới rất
là nhiều người xây cái bộ mà này bộ cái
cái bộ công cụ này LM Wikimedia thì
nhưng mà mình xây xong rồi mình dùng và
xong mình tự cải thiện từng từng từng
bước từng bước từng bước từng bước dần
lên các bạn và các anh chị thì cái nên
mà kho làm xong rồi co chia sẻ cho mọi
người thôi để mọi người cùng dùng chung
thì để có công cụ này thì cái công cụ
này nó vừa cả tiếng Việt và cả tiếng Anh
luôn ha thì các bạn có thể về các bạn
dùng nó cũng rất là đơn giản. Kho có kết
nối với nó cả cái a cái YouTube để hướng
dẫn cho các bạn sử dụng ha. Thì các bạn
à Kho sẽ chia sẻ cái link này cho các
bạn và các bạn có thể về và các bạn dùng
nó ha. Thì về cái cách cài đặt thì một
tí nữa Kho sẽ Kho K kho sẽ chia sẻ cái
cách cài đặt ha. Nhưng mà bây giờ thì
Kho sẽ
khoan nói về cái việc mà mình sẽ chia sẻ
cài đặt nó đi và Kho sẽ nói là những cái
mà những điều mà Kho cực kỳ tâm đắc và
những điều mà Kho ứng dụng được từ cái
cái bộ công cụ này vào trong công việc
của mình, vào trong ứng dụng của mình để
cho nó đạt được hiệu quả tốt nhất. Được
không cả nhà? Cả nhà muốn nghe không ạ?
Muốn nghe không ạ? Nếu muốn nghe thì
nhấn nhấn dùng kho số một đi để kho á là
các bạn rất là hào hứng và nghe cái này
đi ạ.
Dạ. Ok. Ok. Cảm ơn cả nhà. Rồi cái điều
điều đầu tiên Kho muốn chia sẻ cho các
bạn là một cái điều mà những điều mà tâm
đắc nhất của Khoa khi mà sử dụng bộ công
cụ này ha. Nó hay và nó tuyệt vời lắm cả
nhà. Mà cái cảm giác là bây giờ hiện tại
nãy kho cũng chia sẻ với anh Minh đó là
hiện tại như là 70 80% là Kho dùng cái
công cụ này vào chính trong công việc
của mình. Thế thì công cụ này nó hay chỗ
nào mà nó hấp dẫn chỗ nào mà mình dùng?
Bây giờ bác bác buộc xài một cái con sử
dụng một con agent nào khác hoặc là muốn
làm một cái gì khác việc đầu tiên là
khoối vào trong second trend trước rồi
mới nói chuyện tiếp ha. Rồi kho thấy có
một bạn nào muốn ch phát biểu thì cho để
kho chốt xong phần này xong rồi cả nhà
mình trao đổi nhau được không ạ? Ok
không ạ?
>> Ok cứ làm theo lộ trình đi Khoan.
>> Dạ ok.
À việc đầu tiên mà Kho thấy cái ứng dụng
mà nó hay nó hấp dẫn cái chỗ này mà Kho
rất là tâm đắc đó là cái việc đó là mình
có thể mình à
nói ra ai cũng thích coi đó là cái gì ạ?
Tiết kiệm
token. À tiết kiệm token cũng có nghĩa
là cái gì ạ? Tiết kiệm tiền đúng không
ạ? [tiếng cười]
Tiết kiệm token và tiết kiệm tiền. Thì
nếu mà nhiều nếu mà kho không xài kho
không xài ai rất là nhiều và mỗi lần làm
mà các bạn và anh chị cũng cân nhắc là ô
cái công việc này mình có nên làm hay
không, có làm hay không, có làm như thế
nào. Đặc biệt là xài bây giờ mấy cái con
mà mạnh mạnh mạnh giống như con OPUS đó
các bạn và các anh chị hoặc là con CH
GBT 5.5 này thôi rồi nó quất [khịt mũi]
tê tua tơ tả ha. chưa làm gì hết là nó
đã mất tiền rồi. Thế thì cái việc nó
việc đầu tiên là kho sử dụng bộ não
second brand để cái phần quan trọng nhất
của mình đó là tiết kiệm token và nó
tiết kiệm ở chỗ nào?
tiết kiệm cái đầu tiên của nó mà nó tiết
kiệm bằng khá nó ứng dụng được và nó làm
được nó rất là hay ở cái chỗ đó là
kh xíu ok nó là
các phiên làm việc
các section đó các bạn anh chị
Thì nếu mà các bạn làm việc với nhiều
với an thì các bạn hiểu một chuyện đó là
ờ cứ mỗi phiên làm việc các bạn và các
anh chị mình tạo ra mình đang làm việc
với nó xong đó rồi á
mình mình vừa mới làm với nó xong rồi
mình mới chuyển mình đóng máy đi nghỉ là
hoặc là mình tạo ra một phiên khác để
mình làm việc thì coi như là nó quên hết
đúng không ạ?
Có ai gặp trường hợp này chưa? Có ai gặp
trường hợp này chưa? Có ai gặp trường
hợp nhắn nhắn cho phím hai kh biết là
các bạn đã gặp trường hợp này giống kho
đi à.
À
nghĩa là nghĩa nghĩa là sao? Nghĩa là
khi mà co rơm một cái phiên làm việc mới
thì kiểu như là
mình phải đ nghĩa là cái phiên trước là
mình à giải thích là cái dự án này phải
làm như thế này, cái dự án kia là phải
làm như thế kia nhưng mà qua một cái
phiên mới thì coi như là mình phải giải
thích lại vì nó nó đâu có nhớ là hết lại
đâu các bạn chư chị mà muốn để cho nó
nhớ lại hết á là mình phải yêu cầu nó
phải nó phải vô nó nó tìm hiểu lại và nó
phải học lại nên cuối cùng là chúng ta
sẽ bị mất tới token và cái chuyện là nó
sẽ phải đi học lại những cái mà chúng ta
đã chỉ cho nó rồi. Thì đó là một trong
những cái vấn đề của
cái con agent hiện tại là các phiên làm
việc ha. Ờ cái trải nghiệm thì khi mà
kho áp dụng nó trong cái second brain
của nó của kho á là sao? Có những cái
trải nghiệm gọi là cái trải nghiệm gọi
là liền mạch.
Liền mạch là sao? Có nghĩa là sao? Nghĩa
là mình mình làm xong cái phiên đó, mình
đóng cái phiên đó, mình đi nghỉ, hôm sau
mình mở cái phiên đó bắt đầu là à nó sẽ
làm lại giống như nó bắt đầu lại như từ
đầu luôn. Nghĩa là nghĩa là nó nó nhớ
lại những cái mà Khoa đã làm được không
ạ? Và những cái phiên trước à nó đã làm
cái gì và nó nói là ở phiên này tao đã
làm làm gì này cho cho mình nè. Và bắt
đầu khi mà nhảy vô mình làm. Thì cái
điều này cực kỳ quan trọng. Cái chỗ này
các bạn và các anh chị mắt cái con á
hiện tại đi có những cái con mà cái cửa
sổ ngư cảnh cực kỳ lớn giống như con
semini nè, con clot nè, ngay cả những
cái con
open
mãng nguồn mỡ đi giống như cái con
dipsit đi nó là 1 triệu token đúng
không? Nhưng là thực chất là chúng ta
không sử dụng hết 1 triệu token đâu các
bạn nha anh chị. Chắc nó vài phiên với
nhữ những cái dự án mà nặng nặng yêu cầu
nó làm á là ăn chập á là nó bị đơ liền.
À nó cảm thấy các bạn nhìn thấy nó ngu
liền không đúng không ạ? Bởi vì sao?
Không phải là nó ngu các bạn và các anh
chị bắt đầu là cái cửa sổ ngữ cảnh nó
quá lớn nó đọc không có nổi nữa. Và khi
mà mình nhò nhét nhồi nhồi nhồi ngữ cảnh
vô bắt đầu là nó bị lag bị lag lên nhưng
thì kết quả nó sẽ không trả ra mong muốn
giống như mình được. Nên thường như vậy
nên ví dụ nhưững cái phiên làm việc mà
nhiều á bắt buộc khoa section nó lại và
mở một cái section khác. Nhưng mà để cái
bước chuyển cái section là thì kho nhớ
lại trước xong đó rồi mở cái section mới
và coi như là mình đã làm việc nó hiểu
được à mày đang làm việc cái này này
tiếp nè và mày mày mình không cần phải
nhắc lại cho nó.
Hấp dẫn không ạ?
Hấp dẫn không ạ? Thế bây giờ kho sẽ
trình bày ha. Kho kho n n nãy giờ nói
nhiều quá [ho]
bây giờ thực hành tí. Đó là kho sẽ mở ra
cái
cái cái
anticrati đi ha. Chia sẻ về anticity mà
không nói gì về antic thì nó nó dở quá.
Rồi
đợi kho xíu
đây.
Ok.
Đây
ti chạy
rồi
bây giờ khẽ cho án tí của khoa h sao
không thấy ta
à đây ok đây đây là cái anti của kho ha
được không ạ đây phiên đầu tiên làm việc
của kho là cái gì đây là một phiên mới
hoàn toàn đúng không ạ? Đây là cái dự án
second brand của kho nè. Đây là dự án
second của kho nè. Nó một nùi như thế
này nhưng mà nó thực sự nó được sắp xếp
theo một cái cái quy trình của nó các
bạn và các anh chị. Thế thì phiên làm
việc của khoên là cái gì? Thì khoa sẽ
việc đầu tiên là kho bấm vào trong start
up khởi động bộ não. Các bạn nhìn thấy
nè nó có quy trình của nó ha. Start up
được không ạ? khởi động bộ não đầu tiên
thì nó sẽ lại. Phiên làm việc, hai ba
phiên làm việc vừa mới đây của mình
được không ạ? Và nó sẽ tóm tắt là à mày
đang làm cái này này nè, làm này này nè.
Đó. Đây các bạn nhìn thấy nó đang load
nè. Ph dấu gì cho các bạn nha. Nó đang
load nè.
Nó đang load lại những cái phiên làm
việc của mình nè.
Đây đây ha. Nó đang load lại cái phiên
làm việc nè.
Đây đây chữ ngày 29 tháng 6 là ngày hôm
qua. Cái phiên làm việc mới nhất là làm
như này nè. Kết nối bộ não nè. Kết nối
vào trong VPS nè. Ờ hl nè. Đó việc làm
gian dở nè phải không ạ? Thế thì kho chỉ
việc gọi là làm việc trên một cái
section mới hoàn toàn được không ạ? Cái
rồi bắt đầu mình làm việc. mình yêu cầu
nó triển khai dự án, tìm hiểu dự án
nghĩa là coi như là những cái phiên nó
liên tiếp với nhau, mình không phải dừng
lại gián đoạn để mình giải thích cho nó
một cái chuyện gì đó nữa thì nó sẽ đỡ
tốn thời gian cho mình hơn, đỡ tốn token
cái quan trọng nhất là đỡ tốn thời gian
cho mình nhất
được không ạ?
Rồi sau khi mà kết thúc phiên thì Kho sẽ
nếu mà Kho muốn B Kho dùng mà cảm thấy
nó lag đi thì Kho sẽ việc làm gì tiếp
theo kho sẽ thực hiện một cái bọn gọi là
brow up nghĩa là tổng kết của phim nè
bấm một cái lệnh này vào trong đó thì nó
sẽ tự động nó tổng kết nó ghi nhớ lại
những cái mà Khoa đã làm trong cái phiên
đó để chuyển tiếp cho cái phiên ngày hôm
sau.
Rồi ok chúng ta sẽ thảo luận cái vấn đề
này ở đây ha. Rồi các bạn mở mic lên
chúng ta sẽ trao đổi chém gió nhau tí
xíu nha. [tiếng cười]
>> À ok mình có đo lời mình nói trước cái
nha rồi anh em sẽ cùng thảo luận. Sau đó
là nhờ Khoa hướng dẫn cho các anh em tải
cái cái RBO hay là cái cái tool nó về.
Ok không Khoa hả?
>> Dạ ok.
Hiện tại á ở đây có một số bạn là người
mới. Đầu tiên là có một số bạn là mình
biết. À thì chắc chắn khi các bạn nhìn
giao diện anti này nó sẽ là một cái sự
lạ lẫm. Ok chưa ạ? Đó là cái thứ nhất.
Cái thứ hai là những cái phần mà hồi nãy
Khoa có chia sẻ thì chắc chắn luôn sẽ có
một số bạn và một số anh chị
vẫn đang mơ hồ. vẫn đang mơ hồ là không
biết là tại sao có cái này và và và nhìn
cái đống bùi nhùi ở bên tay trái cái
nhìn nguyên một cái cây thư mục đó không
biết nó là cái gì. Ờ thì trước mắt là
mọi người á chúng ta cứ tạm thời chấp
nhận cái việc này nó như là một cái
chàng hiện nhiên nha cả nhà.
À sorry.
Ok. À tạm thời chúng ta cứ chấp nhận một
cái chuyện là người mới cho nên chúng ta
sẽ nghe và để cho bạn Khoa chia sẻ và
mọi người cứ ừ hình dung ra cái câu
chuyện là bữa nay là chúng ta được học
thêm một cái gì đó mới và na ná trong
đầu là cái co cái second r chúng ta khởi
động cái cái cái ngày mới của section mà
nãy giờ bạn Khoa chia sẻ đó. Còn những
cái từ mà chuyên môn nữa, 1 triệu token
hay là output ra như thế nào, những cái
này thì các bạn cần phải có thời gian ha
mới hiểu được là ừ 1 triệu toen nó là
cái gì và tiêu tốn như thế nào thì thật
ra là mọi người phải tự đi tìm hiểu thêm
thôi chứ rất khó để mà có thể hình dung
trong một cái buổi này mà chia sẻ thêm
cho mọi người trong một cái bài toán nó
rất là lớn. Ok rồi mình chỉ có một vài ý
mình chia sẻ thôi. Còn lại anh em có thể
bắt đầu bật mic và chia sẻ trao đổi cùng
với Khoa. Sau đó có thể là Khoa sẽ trao
đổi thêm. Cảm ơn Khoa. Cảm ơn cả nhà.
Ok. Cả nhà có gì trao đổi không?
[tiếng cười]
À nếu mà tiện thì anh em cứ bật mic lên,
còn nếu mà không có thì cứ nhắn đi rồi
mình sẽ đọc cái
cái tin nhắn cho cho mình sẽ làm trợ lý
cho. [tiếng cười]
[kinh ngạc]
>> Dạ. Chào anh Khoa, chào anh Minh. Với
anh Khoai với anh Minh chia sẻ. Alo các
anh bảo chị không ta? Có có
>> ờ cho cho xin phép coi nhà hơi ồn.
>> Ừ
>> rồi. Ok. Cả nhà có nghe bảo rõ không ta?
>> Rồi rõ rõ. Ok.
>> Dạ. Ơ Khoa cho Bảo Bảo hỏi thêm á là
hiện tại bây giờ cái giao diện này á Bảo
thấy là nó là ờ không phải 2.0 á thì nếu
như này á mình làm bằng giao diện 2.0
thì có được không?
Dạ. Ok anh.
>> Dạ. Còn câu hỏi nào nữa không anh? Ờ thứ
hai nữa là
cái mà
trong cái quá trình mà nó nó thứ nhất là
nó có bộ não rồi đúng không? Thì nó nó
nhớ cái phần đầu nó sẽ load được những
cái session trước. Nhưng mà trong quá
trình làm á mà bảo thấy nếu mà không có
bộ não thì nó thấy nó cũng rất là ngáo
tức là trong cái đoạn chat mình quá dài
á.
thì nó nó nó như là nó
nó cứ cải chầy cải cối rồi nó như là nó
quên đi những cái mà cho dù mình đã đóng
skill rồi mình đã bắt nó nó làm á thì
cái này á là nó đã học những sát sinh
trước nhưng mà khi mà mình làm những cái
sát sinh hiện tại á
>> thì nó có bị cái cái mà
>> hơi bị ngáo ngáo vậy không anh anh Khoa
hả?
>> Ngáo ngáo.
>> Dạ. À ok anh. Thì hồi nãy
>> Dạ ok anh. Cái vấn đề duy nhất là như
thế này nè. Cái bởi vì tại sao Kho K kho
bật antiity
ID này không mà Kho không có nói về anti
2.0 thì cái second brand này sử dụng cho
tất cả những cái con agent đều hết được
hết cả. Anti 2 cũng được tất cả đều
dưng. Tí nữa kho sẽ demo cho các bạn xem
ha. và kho kết nối nó như thế nào là một
cái vấn đề thứ hai của nó là tại sao nó
ngáo ngáo ngáo. Thì hồi nãy Kho có có
chia sẻ đó cái vấn đề một trong những
vấn đề mà quan trọng nhất á là cái cái
cửa sổ ngư cảnh token cái cái cửa sổ của
ngư cảnh á thường ví dụ như 1 triệu
token nhưng mà bản thân Kho lấy th xài
khoảng 600.000 tới 700.000 ng là bắt đầu
là thấy nó ngáo ngáo rồi đó là lúc đó là
Kho sẽ đóng đóng cái section nó lại và
mở ra cái section mới thì nó sẽ nó kho
thấy nó cải thiện được cái cái cái độ
lót của nó bởi vì nó sẽ rất là ok. Thì
đó cái đó là thì em em thấy vậy nha.
Dạ ok cái đó cái đó trải nghiệm của em
thôi còn em không biết của anh nó như
thế nào. Dạ rồiạ
còn gì nữa không cả nhà?
Cái chỗ này mình sẽ dậy mình sẽ nói thêm
cái phần contact ngữ cảnh này ha chia sẻ
với anh em tại vì mình cũng có tìm hiểu.
Ờ nếu như anh em mà sử dụng một trong
cái luồng chat á hiểu cơ bản là giống
như Khoa vừa nói hay là cái câu chuyện
mà Bảo vừa hỏi á là ở đây á mình hình
dung nó sẽ có giới hạn về số lượng token
ha. số lượng contex ở trong đó là cái
ngữ cảnh và 1 triệu toen ở đây á là thậc
sự là đó là một cái đối với cái model mà
hiện nay Google công bố đúng không à
Khoa hả là 1 triệu token hãng Google hay
là Cloud hay là thậm chí là cái phiên
bản mới nhất của GBT mình không nhớ
nhưng mà clot ở phiên bản
clot mới nhất thì cũng là phiên bản 4.7
4.8 8 nó cũng là 1 triệu token đó. Tuy
nhiên á là cái 1 triệu token này với
điều kiện là clot là mình trả phí ở bên
nền tảng của clot còn ở đây là đang đấu
nối dán tiếp chứ không phải là trực tiếp
của bên clot coi như nó không được 1
triệu token đâu cả nhà. Đó là mình bỏ
qua cái cái con clot nha. Ok không cả
nhà? Còn nếu như sử dụng cái gravity và
cái model mà phiên bản 3.5 hay 3.1 thì
cái này á thì theo hãng công bố là nó là
1 triệu token á. 1 triệu token là 1
triệu token input vào nha. Còn cái
output là không phải nha cả nhà. Phần
output là mình phải tính riêng nha. Đó
thì ở đây bắt đầu là chưa tới 1 triệu
token đó bắt đầu đã có cái hiện tượng.
À đó có bạn Minh Long mới chia sẻ. Thì
cái cái phần này để mình nói thêm thôi.
Thì sau khi mà nó ngáo ngáo đó thì mọi
người bắt đầu đang có một cái vấn đề là
mình phải chuyển sang cái section mới
hay là cái mình gọi là cái cái cái luồng
chat mới á. Thì ở đây là chính vì vậy mà
Khoa đã ứng dụng cái second range hay là
cái câu chuyện hồi nãy là chỉ cần mở cái
đó lên và yêu cầu nó khởi động lấy lại
cái bối cảnh ngữ cảnh trước đó và nó cứ
vậy mà nó làm việc tiếp thì ở tất cả các
luồng chat mới nó sẽ không ảnh hưởng đến
cái luồng chat trước đó nên Bảo có thể
ứng dụng được mình nghĩ cho cái công
việc hiện nay của Bảo.
Ok rất là cảm ơn anh em.
Anh có có cái nữa Bảo xin hỏi thêm á
hiện tại á Bảo đang chia luồng Bảo đang
chia luồng là thí dụ trong cùng project
đó nhưng mà bả chia luồng thí dụ là đóng
gói sản phẩm chuyên về marketing hoặc là
chuyên về code thì như vậy á mình dùng
vậy mình có kết nối được những cái luồng
đó với nhau được hay không?
À về cái câu hỏi này thì thật ra nó lại
là quay lại cái vấn đề là bảo cần phải
đóng gói lại nha. Cần phải đóng gói một
là đóng gói những cái luồng đó lại thành
một cái chuẩn chung luôn. Có nghĩa là
workflow hoặc là skill tùy theo cái cái
này nó nó thuộc về cái chuyên môn tí
xíu. Thì sau khi mà đóng gói được cái đó
rồi á thì chúng ta sẽ yêu cầu nó đơn
giản là tạo một cái workflow cơ bản
thôi. Tạo một cái workflow cơ bản từ cái
workflow này kết nối với cái workflow
kia tạo ra thành những cái luồng. Còn cơ
bản nhất nữa. Còn nếu mà điển hình nhất
nữa là a+ t luôn cái conversation thằng
này gọi thằng kia. Nhưng mà như vậy cũng
rất là tốn cô rất là tốn toen.
>> Ok thôi để để anh Khoa chia sẻ thêm tiếp
với ơn anh Khoa vui vậ. Dạ cả nhà có ai
hỏi gì nữa không ạ? Trao đổi đi cho nó
vui nó gì đâu mình
>> Khoa là một trong những chuyên gia mà
mình thấy khám phá những cái công cụ mới
mà ứng dụng Aion rất là siêu nha cả nhà.
Nên có gì hôm nay anh em cứ mạnh dạn bào
đi anh em. Còn không có khoa sẽ đi tiếp
chương trình đó.
>> Trao đổi cho vui cái gì đâu. Coi như là
mình thấy mình ứng dụng được mình hay
mình cũng chia sẻ cho anh em thôi. Ừ.
Rồi ok không có gì nữa đúng không ạ?
>> Ok thô. Mời Khoa tiếp tục.
>> Không có gì nữa thì Khoa đi tiếp nha.
[tiếng cười]
Ok. Rồi
tiếp đến cái câu hỏi
mà anh vừa bảo vừa mới hỏi đó là thực nó
là cái phần sau của kho đó là mình ứng
dụng cho các token các cho các con agent
thì ở đây là
đây phim làm việc rồi cái thứ hai nữa
khoa chia sẻ Sare
rồi ok tiết kiệm phiên làm việc rồi ok
thì anh em thường cả nhà thường là kho
có thích trình bày theo kiểu my map như
thế này đôi khi nó dễ hiểu hơn trước giờ
mình làm việc theo kiểu vậy đó một tiết
kiệm so và cái thứ hai của nó là cái con
ha
ờ bây giờ cái con [hắng giọng] này nè
Thì ờ mình không chỉ mình sử dụng cho
con antiquity, nghĩa là các bạn có thể
ban đầu các bạn làm cho antiquity làm
trời làm đất, làm um sừng thứ cũng được,
không có vấn đề gì hết. Nhưng mà cái vấn
đề chừng sau này nếu mà chúng ta mở rộng
qua những cái con khác thì sao? Thì cái
cái cái câu hỏi là ủa lại chúng ta phải
sai lại từ đầu đúng không? Không. Nhưng
mà nếu có bộ cầu áo sand như thế này
ngay lập tức chúng ta kết nối thẳng với
cái con cái con cái con action nào. Rất
là đơn giản rồi rất là dễ chịu ha. chúng
ta sẽ không khó khăn vào trong cái việc
đó được không ạ? Thì ở đây thì kho ví dụ
như ở đây kho thừa kho b ví dụ bây giờ
việc đầu tiên là kho sẽ kết nối trực
tiếp với con à nếu mà anti anti thì
không nói nè ha. Anti antiity
là một nè. Ờ để đây coi
để đây cho nó dễ xem.
Antigravity nè. Antigravity thực chất á
là bởi vì anh
ảnh chia sẻ là anh em xài anti nhiều thì
em chia sẻ nhưng mà thật sự hiện tại và
anti n em không phải là em dùng nhiều em
thường em thường hiện tại giờ em thường
sử dụng si nhiều hơn si nó nhiều cái nó
dễ chạy nhanh gọn lẹ và nó
ầm được [tiếng cười] là em sẽ sử dụng
2.0 luôn ha. 2.0.
>> Nhờ Khoai chia sẻ luôn cái công cụ nãy
Khoai vừa nói luôn đi để cho anh em cùng
biết luôn cái COI mà.
>> Dạ. Dạ. Đ thì em em đang trình bày xong
em chia sẻ luôn nè.
>> Ok.
>> Rồi ờ ví dụ như những cái conent khác ví
dụ như là cái con ờ
ờ cái con cái con gì nhỉ? Ờ Herm đi.
Herm đi ha. thì Kho sẽ kết nối vào bộ
não second nó như thế nào. Tiếp theo ví
dụ như hồi sáng không mới mua tí thi
luôn nè. Cái con
client ha nè
mới sáng mới ra cái thấy đã quá chịu
không nổi quất liền. À đây cho ch mình
thích học hỏi chia sẻ lắm cả nhà. Đây
thế là thế là mình mua luôn con cline
này nè. Mới sáng mới mua luôn nè. Đã
không?
À con cline nè. Đó đó sáng mới mua luôn
về xài kết nối vô second range chạy ầm
ầm ầm ầng ầng ầng luôn ha. R bây giờ
Khoai chia sẻ cho cả nhà luôn ha.
[khịt mũi]
Rồi ờ ở đây nó có khả năng nó hơi khó
hiểu một tí xíu nhưng mà thì mình cứ
chia sẻ đi ha. Rồi à
ờ mình à ủa sao kỳ ta? Chụp lại
rồi. Ok. Được rồi.
Đây
bây giờ kho chia sẻ kho sử dụng trên
những cái con khác nó như thế nào ha.
Đây
là Windows
rồi. Ok. Thì để cho đây đây là cái mô
hình COI
thì nó cái này nó hơi nó hơi bị tí xíu
là mình sẽ gõ dung lệm nhiều nhưng mà nó
có ưu điểm của nó nó chạy rất là nhanh.
Ví dụ nếu là mình sử dụng mấy cái con mà
cái con
cái con ờ An ID á thì nó sẽ phải lo thêm
cái gọi là nó phải kéo thêm cả cái ngữ
cảnh của cái a ờ của cái giao diện á các
bạn anh chị nên nó chạy cũng khá là
nặng. Thế thì bây giờ mình sẽ sử dụng
các bạn nhìn thấy ở đây khoa sẽ nhảy vô
rất là nhanh nếu mà mình sẽ sử dụng cái
cái gì ta?
Rồi ok đợi kho xíu
rồi đây bây giờ kho sẽ nhảy vô con anti
trước đi ha. Anti thường á là kho cũng
không sử dụng cái con cái cái công cụ
máy tính nhiều đâu các bạn và các anh
chị. Mình thường sử dụng COI nhiều mình
thích nó nó xài nó làm nó nhanh mượt
nhanh gọn lẹ và mượt nữa. Thì bây giờ
mình sẽ vô dự án này ha. Dự án của mình
đang ở second brand mình nhảy vô ha. Rồi
mình mình đã cài anti gravity 2 rồi. Đây
đây là câu lệnh mình sẽ vô anti gravity
2 trên si
ờ đây
đây
ha. Đây được không ạ? Đây là cái mô hình
ity. Thì bây giờ ở đây là một cái ha kho
sẽ gõ nó s
đây các bạn nhìn thấy không? Nó khởi
động bộ não nè. Kho đang ở trong cái dự
án second brand nè. Thấy không ạ? À kho
sẽ vô kho startup nó là kho sẽ vô nó
thôi
được không ạ?
Đó là cách mà kho sử dụng antricity CO
nó cũng a đây là 2.0 đó nha cả nhà. Còn
rồi là một ở đây khỏ thoát đi. Cái này
nó hơi ấy một tí xíu, dính một tí xíu
nhưng mà nó hay thì con cũng chia sẻ
luôn. Cái thứ hai nữa là con Hermet. Ví
dụ như vô dự án Secr này ha thì Khoa sẽ
vô con Hermate Hermate vô nó một cái thì
các bạn sẽ nhìn thấy là nó bắt đầu nó vô
nè. Nó vô cái con Hade nè.
là cái con agent á mình vô trong này đây
nó đây mới xài hồi sáng nè nó ra luôn nè
cả nhà [tiếng cười]
di ha ch cái này rồi thì ở đây nè kho sẽ
ví dụ như ở đây là kho đang có những cái
model nè cái cái lệnh mo mà hồi nãy em
nói nè anh anh minh cái lệnh mo nè nó là
kết hợp những cái con agent lại với nhau
để nó trao đổi. Thì ở đây kho con kho sử
dụng cái con homemade thì ở đây kho sử
dụng các bạn nhìn thấy kho lệnh rồi
startup nè coi b khởi khởi động bộ não
ai đầu phiên nè được không ạ? Thì nó sẽ
click vô trong cái dự án và đưa những
cái thông tin của con cái kia vào ở
trong cái bộ não của nó và nó làm nó xử
lý làm việc rất là lẹ luôn. Thì đó là
một trong những cái hay của cái này.
Hoặc là cái con xe con cl mà sáng nay
vừa mình vừa vừa mới làm nè.
Line nè là kho vừa mới mua nó luôn, mới
mua sáng nay và kho ứng dụng nó vào
trong cái second brand của mình. Nghĩa
là để cho nó kết nối vào trong cái cái
second brand của mình n các bạn nè. Sale
nè line nè ha.
Start startup nè. Coi đồng bộ nào nè có
luôn nè. Đúng không ạ? Mình gõ cái là
bắt đầu nó sẽ load lại hết cái dự cái dữ
liệu từ dự án của mình thì nó bắt đầu nó
triển khai vậy thôi. Thì đó là một trong
những cái mà hay nhất của
second brand mà mình triển khai mình
triển khai và mình dùng.
Rồi.
Ok chưa anh Bảo? [tiếng cười]
Ngay ngay đúng câu hỏi của anh luôn á.
Đó thì đó là cái mà em chia sẻ. Ờ
ok
rồi.
Ờ có câu hỏi gì? Cả nhà mình có câu hỏi
gì không? Không có câu hỏi. Có câu hỏi
gì không? À n cái phần này nó cũng chung
chung nhau chứ nó cũng không có gì riêng
biệt với cái phần gọi là tiết kiệm cái
phiên làm việc. Chỉ khác biệt một cái
chỗ đó là thay vì chúng ta làm việc ở
trên section thì ở đây chúng ta chuyển
sang môi trường làm việc cho mấy con với
nhau thôi. Nó chỉ như vậy thôi chứ nó
không có gì khác biệt cả. Được không ạ?
Rồi ok thôi để kho chuyển cái phần hấp
dẫn hơn ha. Nó để cho các bạn dễ hiểu
hơn và hấp dẫn hơn.
Rồi
tiếp theo
đây cả nhà. Cái mà kho cực kỳ tâm đắc.
Ủa cái tâm đắc đâu ta? À cái phần này
phải là tâm đắc mới đúng. À
rồi ok. Phần này cực kỳ tâm đắc mà Khoa
thấy nhiều, mình học được nhiều và mình
thấy mình trải nghiệm được nhiều.
Đó chính là cái kiến thức.
Cái kiến thức á cả nhà. Cái kiến thức mà
mình học từ nó. Mình học từ cái chính
những cái con agent của mình luôn.
Ờ thay vì á
ở con agent này nè nó có một cái hay của
nó đó là ờ chúng ta
ví dụ những cái mà chúng ta đang học đi
gọi là chúng ta sẽ cập nhật với nó những
cái kiến thức mới.
Ví dụ như Kho chia sẻ cái cách mà mình
cập nhật vào những kiến thức mới đi ha.
Rất là đơn giản các bạn xem Khoa làm
luôn.
Đây ví dụ như mình đọc một cuốn sách mới
mình thấy một cái đoạn trick play thế là
bắt đầu mình lấy cái đó về và mình nạp
vào trong cái bộ bộ não dữ liệu của mình
và mình coi nó như là một cái kiến thức
mới hoàn toàn được không ạ? Để mình cập
nhật và cập nhật vào ở trong cái cơ sở
dữ liệu của mình ha. Đây để coi coi top
đây coi share cho các bạn.
Thường thì mình dùng ít nhiều, mình ít
khi mà mình dùng
mình mình dùng ít nhiều bởi vì nhiều
kiến thức của đó nó hay và nhiều chuyên
gia họ chia sẻ cũng khá là hay. Thí dụ
nha ha, con thấy một kiến thức cực kỳ
hay nè. Kiến thức cực kỳ hay nè, nội
dung hay nè, đúng không ạ? Thì á kho
copy cái kiến thức này về đây. Kho copy
nó kiến thức này nó về được không ạ?
Copy nó về.
Rồi
để kh share toàn màn hình đi luôn cho nó
cho cả nhà dễ xem.
Rồi vậy nó dễ hơn đúng không cả nhà? Ok
không ạ? Thấy hết màn hình rồi đúng
không ạ?
Ok thấy khoai
>> rồi. Ok thấy kiến thức này hay kho copy
nó về và kho qua ID ha. ID xong rồi kho
cl nó lại. Kho kho cập nhật kiến thức nó
lại. Xong đó rồi kho tạo một cái file
gọi là cái file MD kiến thức mới. Ví dụ
vậy ha. Kiến thức mới sóng chấm md. Rồi
xong ở đây là một cái file MD thôi. Xong
pass nó vào ở trong cái này đi. Đây là
coi như là một kiến thức mới được không
ạ? Thế thì công việc tiếp theo của Kho
là cái gì? Kho nạp cái kiến thức mới này
vào trong cái bộ não second brain của
Kho để cho con AEN nó học. Mình biết là
một chuyện nha. Mình biết là một chuyện
nhưng mà cái quan trọng nhất là con AEN
nó có biết hay không. Nghĩa là mình với
nó các bạn hiểu là mình học nó cũng học.
Hai người cùng học với nhau và cùng hỗ
trợ nhau và đôi khi nó học nhanh hơn
mình, nó phát triển trước hơn mình nữa
và nên nó kéo mình lên. Các bạn hiểu ý
mình không? Các bạn hiểu ý cái chỗ này
không ạ? Nghĩa là phương pháp học của
mình là như thế này. Không phải là mình
học mình biết xong mình ứng dụng phải
không? Mình với nó cùng học xong rồi
mình nạp kiến thức nó vào trong bộ này
và nó học và nó hiểu được rồi ha. Thì
kho sẽ sử dụng nó. Bây giờ ví dụ như bây
giờ kho nạp kiến thức này bằng cách nào?
Thì kho có một cái câu lệnh gọi là
brand inap. Các bạn nhìn thấy cái chỗ
nạp dữ liệu vào second brand không?
Các bạn nhìn thấy họ nạp dữ liệu vào
second ró
thấy không cả nhà?
Đây đây ha. Đây là câu lệnh nó là cái
skill nó là skill mà kho cũng đã để ở
trên trên đây rồi cả nhà không có giấu
gì cả nhà hết nó để kho có ở trong đây.
Khi mà các bạn down cái app này về thì
các bạn sẽ có cái skill này luôn nó có
đầy đủ skill ở trong này luôn nè. Nó có
skill này
nè. Nó có những cái skill nạp dữ liệu
đây. Agent workflow nè. Nó tên của nó là
inget. Inget nạp dữ liệu vào row. Nạp dữ
liệu vào ha.
thì kho sẽ inject cái kiến thức này vào
rồi được không ạ? Để nó nạp vào row của
mình. R là cái phần này nè cả nhà. Cái
phần này chính là cơ sở dữ liệu để bắt
đầu nó nạp vào tiếp vào trong cái
Wikipedia ha. Thì kho sẽ yêu cầu nó nạp
vào trong đây và nó sẽ các bạn cứ cứ cứ
hình dung là nó nạp vào đi. Nghĩa là
mình đưa cho nó một tài liệu và nó sẽ
nạp vào trong cái bộ cột bộ máy
Wikipedia của mình được không ạ? Ok.
Hiểu chỗ này đúng không ạ?
Hiểu chỗ này không ạ?
Rồi nó nạp vào trong cái Wikimedia này.
Và sau khi vào Wikimedia này thì nó sẽ
tạo thành cho mình một cái
đây
cái index.
Hồi nãy Kho có nói chia sẻ với các bạn á
là cái index này nè là cái cơ sở dữ liệu
nó giống như là Wikipedia vậy các bạn.
Anh chị nó sẽ tóm tắt mình. Ở đây các
bạn sẽ nhìn thấy nè.
Aen
nè là cái gì nè. Nó giải thích nè. Tóm
tắt nè. được không ạ? Và khi mà mình
muốn một khi mà một cái kiến thức nào
đó, một dữ liệu nào đó mình muốn đi sâu
hơn là mình chỉ cần click vào trong đây
rồi nó sẽ đi sâu vào hơn. Thường á cái
này á là mình sẽ không sử dụng cái à để
mình đọc. Nó có một cái công cụ tên là
Obsident để nó đọc dữ liệu này. Đây đã
có cho các bạn xem tên luôn nó là
obsiden.
Để mình đọc dữ liệu này. Đây tên của nó
là offsident. Đọc dữ liệu này này. Wiki
index nè. Đây là những bài những bài
viết nè các bạn. Anh chị nó sẽ cập nhật
thống kê. Nghĩa là nó giống như mình các
bạn anh chị. Nghĩa là cái wiki mình cứ
vô mình sắp xếp sắp xếp xếp xếp xếp dữ
liệu trong đó trong đó được không ạ?
Được không ha? Đây để sau đó là tất
nhiên không phải là mình viết nha mà
agent của mình viết cho mình để cho nó
tự kết nối vào những cái bắ link. Và sau
khi mà chúng ta sau một thời gian xây
dựng dài rồi đó, chúng ta sẽ có một cái
gọi là bộ não như thế này. Đâ nhìn nhìn
thấy bộ não chưa?
Đây nhìn thấy bộ não chưa cả nhà?
Rõi không? Đây đây là bộ não nó sẽ linh
hết tất cả những cái bài viết, những
kiến thức nó giống như bộ não cái neon
thần kinh của mình vậy các bạn. Ví dụ
như bây giờ col ví dụ như con IR đi nó
sẽ đọc kiến thức như thế nào? Nó nhảy vô
đây nó đọc vô trong cái wiki xong rồi nó
tìm những cái kiến thức mà liên quan.
Thay vì nó đọc hết nó sẽ rất là tốn rất
là nhiều token. Nó chỉ đọc những cái dữ
liệu nào mà thực sự quan trọng và nó cần
thiết mà nó đang cần thì nó sẽ đọc vô.
Ví dụtic
engineering là cái gì? Nó click vào
trong đây nó tiếp tục nó đi đi đi đi
tiếp được không ạ? Thì đó cách gọi là
cách nạp dữ liệu vào trong cái wiki nạp
dữ liệu vào và từ cái liệu này nó sẽ học
được những kiến thức mới. Quan trọng
nhất là học được những kiến thức mới thì
nó sẽ nâng cấp cái bộ não của mình lên.
Ờ chỗ này hơi nạnh nhỉ. [tiếng cười]
Chúng ta chắc thảo luận tí xíu đi ha.
Rồi mình nói chuyện tiếp nha. Ok.
Rồi cả nhà có vấn đề gì không? Thực ra
là chỗ cái phần mà bộ não thứ hai mà áp
dụng Obsidian á thì có lẽ cũng có một số
anh em biết hoặc là số anh em đã dùng
rồi á thì có thể hiểu. Nhưng với các bạn
mà chưa dùng
cái phần obsidian kết nối với cái đó và
bảo a Khoa vừa chia sẻ thì có lẽ chắc
hơi rối hơi hơi nặng tí xíu tại vì đi
qua rất nhiều Asian xong rồi bây giờ đẩy
qua luôn cái obsidian thì nhìn nó hơi
rối đi.
>> Dạ.
Ờ thì đó thì
đó cái nói chung là
ít nhất các bạn cũng có thể là v bởi vì
cái những cái kiến thức này dữ liệu này
nó cũng khá là nhiều. Ờ còn mà một buổi
thì chắc không có không có đổ v lại cái
thứ hai nữa là lại nhưng mà ít nhất
trong cái buổi hôm nay các bạn biết là à
có cái đó xong rồi mình gỡ từ từ ra mình
mình biết là như thế nào được không ạ.
Thì đó là một trong những cái bánh cái
bánh bánh
>> à để mình giải thích thêm cái chỗ này
cho anh em hình dung tí xíu nè. Cái tại
sao lại sử dụng obsidian mà tại sao lại
dùng cái cái cái giống như trường hợp
hồi nãy Khoa mới sử dụng ha. Thì ở đây á
mình hình dung nhé, tất cả các dữ liệu
hiện nay trên tất cả các nền tảng AI mà
sử dụng trên máy tính cái dạng hay là
tất cả những cái dạng mà dữ liệu mà AI
dễ đọc nhất luôn á là file MCO, file MD
đó cả nhà. Ngoài file MDO thì còn một số
định dạng nó dễ đọc nữa. Tuy nhiên á
mình
phải hình dung ra cái câu chuyện mà hồi
nãy Khoa đang đưa chia sẻ đó là Wiki ha.
Wiki cái câu chuyện đây là trong cái anh
mà Obsidian ảnh đọc được là Wikiyink nó
sẽ link được với nhau những cái tài liệu
đó và đặc biệt là những cái file M down
đó nó sẽ nó sẽ link được với nhau và nó
ráp view cái đó chức năng gọi là rá view
giống như những cái neuron thần kinh tuy
nhiên
>> tuy nhiên nha mọi người nhớ là chỗ điểm
này chúng ta rất khó để đọc những cái
nội dung đó nếu
mắt thường
Mình nói luôn cái này là thật ra không
phải mình nói mà rất là nhiều các cộng
đồng sau khi dùng cái này. Mục đích để
dùng cái đó để làm gì ạ? Để cho ai đọc
chứ phải cho người đọc. Nên mọi người
hình dung nhé. Cái câu chuyện này để cho
ai đọc phải quay lại cái câu chuyện
giống như nãy Khoa có nhấn mạnh á. Cuối
cùng là cái gì? Khi mà lượng dữ liệu của
chúng ta nó quá lớn, mình học ai học và
khi cần chích xuất lại cái dữ liệu đó
thì ở đây mình chỉ cần nói một cái câu
lệnh đơn giản thôi. Hãy lấy cho tôi cái
dữ liệu đó ra. Tôi nhớ là tôi đã có học
rồi mà thì lấy cái đó ra. Và nó nằm ở
đâu thì lập tức ai sẽ bốc ra được liền.
Mọi người hình dung không ạ? Tại vì AI
đọc dữ liệu là qua file Mdown và những
cái file MCO này được link với nhau bởi
một cái gì ạ? Wiki link được không ạ? Và
nó show ra ở trên Obsidian nó sẽ link
được với nhau theo dạng nơi trong thần
kinh ở trong não mình á. Đó là cái mà
Obsidian nó review ra nó gọi là drop
view. Chứ còn bình thường á chúng ta
không thể nào mà chúng ta căng mắt ra
chúng ta zoom zom zoom zoom rồi click
vào từng đó. Không có đâu cả nhà. Không
có đâu. Ai ai nó đọc á chứ không phải
mình đọc đâu. Đó là mình chia sẻ thêm
thôi. Còn cái nội dung nhá. Nội dung thì
ok. Anh em có thể là click vào giống như
trường hợp mà nãy của Khoa mình đi vào
thẳng cái file đó sau khi nó nó tìm ra
rồi thì mình click vào cái nội dung đó
để mình đọc cái nội dung đó. Thay vì
mình đứng từ ở trong cái nền tảng Asian
ví dụ như là anti Gravity bảng IDA thì
làm sao mà anh em có thể đọc được nhé.
Nhưng mà với 2.0 anh em rất khó đọc cái
nội dung bảng cái bảng đó. hoặc là anh
em đứng ở giao diện là CLI có nghĩa là
giao diện mà màn hình command line thì
rất khó để đọc cái nội dung đó. Chính vì
vậy mình phải dùng obsidian để mà view
cái nội dung nó ra. Đó là một cái ý thứ
hai nữa. Ok ha. Rồi thì cái phần mình
này mình trao đổi thêm thôi. Còn anh em
có câu hỏi thì cứ bật mic hoặc là nhắn
tin mình đọc cho Khoa chia sẻ.
>> Ờ có một câu hỏi đó là ờ những cái tài
liệu mình nạp vào trong đây là cái gì?
Thì nói chung là nhiều kiến thức nó nó
liên quan với nhau các bạn và các anh
chị khi mà các bạn đưa có một cái tài
liệu ha nó sẽ đọc và nó sẽ đọc thêm một
cái tài liệu khác và thấy nó có link
nhau nha các bạn nó link nhau thì nó sẽ
kết nối với nhau thành một cái bink để
nó kết nối với nhau được không ạ ví dụ
như là nó đọc một cái dữ liệu đó là về
nghĩa là ở trong dữ liệu công ty của các
bạn thôi cũng được chứ không cần là phải
là quá phức tạp đâu. Ví dụ như là ờ
lương kế toán rồi công ty rồi như thế
này. Hiện tại là Kho vẫn đang ứng dụng
vào trong cái cái việc đó các bạn và các
chị. Công việc hàng ngày của Kho luôn cả
ngay cả những cái công việc của mình
luôn. Ví dụ mình chơi thở thao cũng vậy.
Em em cũng chơi PBon đó anh. Nay học
được mới cứu R đồ cũng ghê lắm. Xong đó
rồi à hỏi là ủa
>> Dạ. [tiếng cười]
>> Xong đó ủa nói sao? Xong đó rồi mình
mình lấy những cái kiến thức đó mình
mình đưa vào trong cái bộ não của mình
và xong đó rồi từ những cái bộ từ kiến
thức đó nó nó kết nối à tại sao mình
mình như vậy như vậy chứ không phải nhất
thiết là ờ những cái kiến thức kỹ thuật
đâu các bạn và các anh chị kiến thức vào
đời thường nghĩa là con nó hiểu được
mình nó hiểu kiến thức của mình cùng với
nó hai người học với nhau đôi khi nó đôi
khi nó giống như một người đừng nói
người bạn nó hơi quá nó người thầy nó
mentor của mình N các bạn anh chị mình
học mình hỏi nó nó kéo lên kéo kéo kéo
mình lên thì đó là hiện tại đó là cái
cách mà cô đang học mà mình thấy nó hữu
ích những cái cái cái khi mà nó có bộ
não vô rồi trời ơi nó nó hay lắm các bạn
và các anh chị thường á các bạn để ý
>> thường để ý đi các bạn cứ để ý là một
cái chuyện gì đó đi. Các bạn phải hiểu
xong các bạn ứng dụng đúng không?
Đúng không ạ? Học hiểu xong rồi ứng dụng
đúng không ạ? Mình phải hiểu nó mới ứng
dụng chứ. Nhưng mà bây giờ cách học là
cái gì? biết nhờ ứng dụng xong rồi mình
học tiếp kiểu là dạng như vậy các bạn
anh chị nó sẽ đưa cho mình những cái góc
nhìn khác nó h rất là tuyệt vời. Xong đó
rồi mình mình học từ những cái cái kiến
thức đó nghĩa là nó kéo mình lên ha. Rồi
thì đó là cái phần cái phần cái phần mà
học kiến thức mới đúng không ạ? Nhưng có
một cái phần mà con nghĩ là cực kỳ giá
trị. Nếu mà các bạn biết là các bạn sẽ
tiết kiệm token nó cũng là một câu
chuyện tiếp cận tiết kiệm token được
không ạ? Và nó chính là cái đinh của
buổi ngày hôm nay nè. Được không ạ? Các
bạn tập trung nha. Được không?
Được không ạ? Tập trung không ạ?
>> Quá được đi chứ. À anh em cho số số một
hay là cho trái tim đi nè. [hắng giọng]
>> [tiếng cười]
>> Tất cả hồi nãy giờ tất cả dồn tất cả mọi
thứ ở cái cái cái kia cái rear thôi. Còn
cái này là cái kho nghĩ đó là cái tất cả
những cái mà giờ gọi là kho đúc kết lại
được kho học được nhiêu đây à coi như là
luyện hết bí kiếp võ công để chia sẻ cho
anh em được không ạ?
>> Quá được.
>> Tuyệt vời không ạ? Ok thì Khoa sẽ chia
sẻ cho các bạn cái cái phần đinh của
phần này. Thực chất á kỹ thuật nó dễ lắm
các bạn. Các bạn kỹ thuật nó dễ lắm. Cài
kiết đồ nó dễ lắm. Các bạn đưa cái bây
giờ các bạn biết thì các bạn à đưa cho
con
ài nó cài cài dễ lắm. Còn cái quan trọng
mình ứng dụng vào được công việc của
mình, mình xài được mình phát triển nó
mới hay đúng không ạ? Còn những cái mà
cái cái cái cái
kia nó đơn giản lắm, không có vấn đề gì
ha. Bây giờ kho sẽ hướng kho sẽ chia sẻ
cái phần đinh này được không ạ? Được
không ạ?
>> Quá được.
>> Comment 1 2 3 gì đó cho kho vui nè.
[tiếng cười]
Ok. Rồi bây giờ kho chia sẻ tiếp ha.
Cái phần hay nhất của phần này và mình
rất là tâm đắc
đó chính là
các bạn anh chị
không phải là những kiến thức mới. kiến
thức mới mình có thể mình học mình nạp
vô được
mà cái gì quan trọng nhất không cuộc đời
mình cái gì các bạn biết là những cái mà
quý giá nhất không kiến thức của người
ta cũng chỉ là kiến thức của người ta
đúng không các anh chị đúng không ạ
những cái gì mà mình trải qua được thì
đó mới chính là kiến thức của mình các
bạn đồng ý với mình chuyện đó không
ủa sao em ru vậy trời hay sao vậy trời
[tiếng cười]
kiến thức người ta đưa cho mình đó chỉ
cũng chỉ là kiến thức ngồi lời thôi.
Những cái gì mà mình trải qua được thì
nó mới chính là của mình
được không ạ? Hợp lý không? Hợp lý
không?
Hợp lý. Nhấn số hai cho kh biết cái nhấn
số hai cho kh biết là nó hợp lý coi nè.
Nè các bạn sẽ cùng học với agent của
mình bằng một cách người ta
ờ gọi là trải nghiệm. Khi dùng từ trải
nghiệm ha.
cố gắng là dùng những cái từ thuật ngữ
khật chắc á cái phần này ch phần chia sẻ
nó khó nhất trong cái phần chia sẻ khó
nhất á là có những cái gọi là thuật ngữ
mà mình cố gắng mình làm sao để cho cả
nhà được hiểu á thì mình cố gắng mình sử
dụng những cái từ gọi là cố gắng là cá
nhân hóa thuật ngữ gọi là tư duy là bắt
học nhưng mà ngôn ngữ thì cố gắng bắt
hai đúng không ạ nên con cố gắng là tìm
những cái từ 4:00 sáng là thức là tìm
những cái từ này nè ủa hay tìm những cái
từ nào để cho mọi người hiểu nhỉ sợ
nhiều quá bị rói
Thì đó Kho sẽ chia sẻ cho các bạn đó là
từ những cái trải nghiệm.
Cái trải nghiệm này nằm ở đâu? Ở trong
cái
cái section vừa rồi. Các bạn có nhớ hồi
nãy các bạn có nhớ là cái startup của
one up không?
Có nhớ không ạ?
>> Hả?
>> Rồi ok. Nhớ là tốt. Tưởng là sợ quên.
[tiếng cười]
Đó chính là những cái trải nghiệm mà các
bạn học được.
Nghĩa là học ở đây là cái những cái bạn
ví dụ như là ờ làm sao để cưa đổ cô cô
cô ấy đúng không ạ? Lần đầu thì bị thất
bại, lần thứ hai là thành công hơn, lần
thứ ba thì ok hơn đúng không? Kiểu kiểu
kêu kiểu dạng như vậy. Thì ở đây là
những cái những trải nghiệm ở đây kho
không có nói về cái mình tự trải nghiệm
mà mình trải nghiệm của mình với những
con Asian. Các bạn hiểu ý mình không?
trải nghiệm của mình với con Asian cụ
thể nó là như thế nào?
Ờ trải nghiệm của mình với những cái con
Asian kho gọi nó là những set
gọi là những cái phên chat đó các bạn và
các anh chị. Các bạn nhớ là hồi nãy Kho
có chia sẻ với các bạn là những cái
section nè. Đây những cái section này
đâu ta?
Đợi xíu, đợi xíu.
Đây sát đây.
Toàn bộ dự án của kho nằm ở trong đây
hết được không ạ? Toàn bộ dự án của kho
đều nằm ở trong đây hết đúng không ạ? Và
những dự án này đều kho đều lưu trữ lại
những cái lần thành công và những lần
thất bại
được không ạ? Đây nó tổng kết nè. Ồ ngày
mấy tháng mấy nè? năm mấy nè, mày đã
từng làm cái này nè, mày đã bị người yêu
bỏ nó như thế nào nè, mày đã bị cô ấy đá
như thế nào nè, rút những kinh nghiệm từ
đó ra nè, đúng không ạ? Ok không ạ? Và
từ những cái cái cái thành công và thất
bại mình này nè, mình sẽ nạp dữ liệu vào
trong second của mình thì lúc đó kiến
thức đó là kiến thức của mình được không
ạ? Từ những cái phiên làm việc, từ những
cái dự án làm việc nó sẽ lưu trữ lại vào
ở trong cái second brand nó ghi nhớ nó.
Họ nói là một cái đơn giản nhất mà nó
tiết kiệm và nó hay cỡ này nè các bạn,
các anh chị làm sao mà nó biết được cái
nhân dự án của các bạn nó như thế nào
đúng không ạ? Những kiến thức mới làm
sao nó biết được nhưng mà những dự những
cái mà các bạn đã trải qua trong cái dự
án đó. Ví dụ kho nói đơn giản như thế
này đi cho các bạn dễ hiểu. Ví dụ như
cái section này đi,
đó là tôi đã làm được
năm lần thất bại và một lần thành công
đúng không ạ? Các bạn đưa dự án đưa các
bao giờ các bạn đưa vào con agent á nó
bao giờ nó cũng gợi ý hai ba cái ba bốn
cái hướng đúng không các bạn? Các anh
chị có không?
đúng không ạ? Tôi tôi gặp cái vấn đề đó
nhưng mà không phải hướng nào nó cũng
thành công. Có những hướng thành công và
có những hướng thất bại trong dự án đó.
Và chỉ các bạn có thể nếm được trải được
nỗi đâu đó thôi chứ không ai nếm trở nỗi
đâu đó cho các bạn cả. Và con nó cũng
nếm cùng các bạn luôn. Và sau khi mà nó
cái các bạn sẽ nạp cái dữ liệu từ những
cái phiên làm việc này vào trong cái con
và nó thấy rằng là à cái phiên làm việc
đó cái dữ dự án đó cái dữ liệu đó là cái
cái cái một nè.
Cái hướng một là thành công, năm hướng
kia là thất bại. Và chừng sau khi mà nó
gặp lại, nó kết nối lại vào trong second
brand thì nó nói là à tôi phải đi hướng
một chứ mới hướng kia tôi không có đi.
Có phải các bạn tiết kiệm được token
không? Đi dự án nhanh hơn không?
Các bạn hiểu ý kho không ạ?
Nghĩa là ở đây ngoài cái việc mà các bạn
học kiến thức mới thì chúng ta học chính
là những trải nghiệm của các bạn. học từ
những cái các bạn đang làm rồi sau đó
mình ứng dụng vào trong second brand
không những các bạn ứng dụng được mà con
Asian của các bạn ứng dụng được thì đó
chính là những cái mà mình nghĩ đó là
thú vị nhất của cái second brain cái
đinh của second brand cái lỗi của second
brand đó chính là học từ những trải
nghiệm của này của của từ những thất bại
những thành công của mình được không ạ
để note lại dễ hơn các bạn nhớ thì các
bạn note lại.
Bản thân mình cũng vậy, mình cũng sẽ ghi
vào trong cái phần chat cùng ghi là trải
nghiệm được không ạ? Để note ngày hôm
nay. Ok.
Ok không ạ? Để cho à đúng không ạ? Học
chúng ta học từ những trải nghiệm của
mình. Aent cũng vậy. Nó cũng giống như
con người cũng học từ chính những trải
nghiệm đó. Thì đó chính là cái điểm thú
vị nhất mà cô đúc kết lại trong tất cả
những cái quá trình à
mình trải nghiệm với camera.
Rồi xong. [tiếng cười]
Còn còn cái phần hướng còn cái phần
hướng dẫn á trời ơi nó dễ lắm các bạn.
có chuẩn bị
cho các bạn cái file a của cái cái của
của cái a đường link [ca hát]
>> cái đường link wiki nè revo nè có đầy đủ
mà
>> là một cái thứ hai nữa kho cũng có chuẩn
bị thêm cho các bạn cái video YouTube nè
ba bước xây dựng wiki nè còn nếu mà
không hiểu nữa là gì dễ nhất là cọc copy
nguyên cái link này đưa vào cái con nó
hỏi là giờ tao không muốn xài cái này
sao nó xài cái đ cái vấn đề không phải
là cài mà cái cái quá trình chúng ta sử
dụng nó cái cái quá trình chúng ta kết
nối và quá trình chúng ta làm với nó
được không ạ? Thì đó là kho chỉ cho các
bạn cái phần đó là cái phần quan trọng
nhất của cái buổi hôm nay rồi. Chắc
chúng ta giải đáp nhau tí xíu nha.
Nghe chất lượng quá Khoa ơi.
Thật sự là
>> cái cái phần này cái bữa nay mình học
được thêm cái cổ khoa. Cái phần này
trước đây á là mình đã có cái ứng dụng
là khi mà những cái section mình chỉ ứng
dụng đến một cái phần thôi nha chứ không
nói được như khoa nhưng mà có nghĩa là
những cái phần nào mà cốt lỗi trong cái
phần section ha mà nó hay á mình sẽ yêu
cầu nó chích xuất thành file MCO. Chích
xuất ngược ra thành file MCO. Sau đó
mình yêu cầu nó lưu trữ đẩy lên lại
notion. Kiểu kiểu như vậy nha. Nhưng mà
hôm nay qua cái cũ khoa thì mình thấy là
đúng là hoàn toàn khác. Thì những cái mà
cái bài học mà trải nghiệm đó mà đưa lại
chính nó để nó học. Tại vì tất cả những
cái buổi mà đầu Khoa có nói á khi mà
mình kết thúc một cái phim chat section
là gần như nó đã mất hút rồi. Nó gần như
đã mất rồi. Nó không còn nhớ nữa. Và cái
việc này mà để cho nó chích suốt lại
những section đó nó lưu trữ lại để chính
nó học. Và chính mình cũng build một cái
dự án và vừa rồi mình bị mất cái dự án
đó mình cảm thấy nó rất là đau nha mọi
người. Đau cực kỳ đau luôn. Mình phải
mất hai ngày mình làm xong cái dự án đó.
Nhưng mà sau khi mà mất cái dự án đó rồi
á mà để tìm lại được, phục hồi lại được
thì thật sự là giống như Khoa nói nếu mà
có những cái section đó thì nó sẽ biết
đường và nó biết cách để mà ấy. Thật ra
là mình cũng có backup chứ không phải có
không có backup đâu. Nhưng mà mình v lại
cũng phải mất khá nhiều thời gian trong
cái việc mà để đi hiểu và đọc lại chính
những cái phần mà trong cái nội dung
section chat đó. Làm đúng hai ngày liên
tục mà tới mấy giờ sáng chứ không phải
thường nha.
Thì
nên buồn quá đi nhảy dù hả anh?
[tiếng cười]
>> Nhảy dù là mới đây thôi.
>> À vậy hả? Tưởng buồn tưởng buồn quá đi
nhảy dù chứ.
>> Đi chơi hai tuần lễ thấy nhảy dù vui
quá.
>> Ok thì đó là một cái phần góc nhìn của
mình và chia sẻ thêm của mình. Còn anh
em có thể chia sẻ thêm cái góc nhìn của
anh em và có câu hỏi cứ đặt với Khoa nha
anh em.
Ok. Cảm ơn Khoa chia sẻ. Cảm ơn Minh.
thì cũng là bảo đây [tiếng cười]
cũng hơi nhiều chuyện xíu nhưng mà chắc
thấy anh Khoa chia sẻ hay quá. Hồi nãy
đi đón bé con thì nó cũng nghe được nghe
không? Nhưng mà khoan nói về cái phần
cài đặt đó thì bảo thấy thứ nhất giống
như Minh nói á thì mình tự tin một cái
là nếu như nó có cái từng session như
vậy á thì mình nó là một cái điểm backup
b cho mình luôn rồi để mình có thể là
mình quay ngược lại những cái session đó
và mình có thể là mình return cái cái mà
mình cảm thấy là nó ok nó cái cái cái
project mình nó đang ok tại thời điểm đó
thì có mình có thể làm được đúng không
anh Khoa?
>> Đúng rồi. Bạn hiểu vấn đề rồi đó. Vấn đề
chỉ đơn giản như vậy thôi.
>> Rồi cái thứ hai nữa thì à mình second rù
học. Ờ nhưng mà á ờ nó là cái bộ não thứ
hai của mình. Thì khi mình học sai thầy
hoặc là mình sai của âm chân kinh mà
mình học trang cuối một cái là mình bị
tậu quả nhập ma đó. Anh hiểu không? Thì
làm sao mình đúng là mình pickup là cái
tài liệu đó, cái idea đó và cái cái ý
kiến đó trên mạng tôi backup ở đâu tôi c
tôi nhặt ở đâu cũng vậy nhưng mà mình
đâu có là nó là đúng đ không mình cảm
thấy hay thôi nhưng mình chưa có su là
đúng nhưng mà wiki ở đây á thì nó là kim
chỉ nam cho mình thì bộ não này thật sự
là bộ não của mình chứ không phải bộ não
của người khác đúng không mình trong quá
trình mình trend nó rồi mình mình làm nó
thì bả hiểu như vậy. Hồi nãy giờ bả bả
nghe thì Bảo hiểu như vậy. Thì làm sao á
mình có thể là thứ nhất có hai cái trong
đầu mình nghĩ là khi mà mình collect
những cái ý kiến trên mạng hoặc là gì
mình cảm thấy hay cái kiến thức mình cảm
thấy hay thì làm sao mình đưa vào bộ não
và nó có cái sự xác nhận là ok nó có sự
chính xác là cái thứ nhất. Cái thứ hai
là nó phải đưa đúng cái học kéo đó. Tại
vì ở đây á hai người cùng học nhưng mà
làm là mày phải làm cho tao ạ. chứ không
phải tao làm đúng không? Thì thật sự là
cái não của mình đâu phải là não của ai
thì khi mà làm á thì ai nó tự chích xuất
nó tự mở những cái ngăn kéo đó nó sẽ
liên liên kết lại tại vì trong một đống
rồi bảo nó đóng bùi nhùi đó đi nó rất là
trần mạng nhện như vậy á thì hai
người cùng học là đúng kiến thức của
mình sẽ được kích hoạt nhưng mà lúc mà
làm á thì mình không thể nào mình mình
lấy trong đầu mình ra thì khi đó đó là
cái người làm chính là cái bộ não thứ
hai mình sẽ làm thì có hai cái hỏi anh
Khoa á là thứ nhất là mình làm sao mình
chứng minh được cái cái cái idea cái mà
mình lượm nhặt về nó đúng
>> ngay lúc đó luôn. Thứ hai là nó làm sao
mà nó nó phân loại được. Ờ thí dụ là nó
nó sẽ phân lại được và nó đưa đúng cái
ngăn ngăn học đó để khi mà nó cần á khi
vô project nó khi vô cái gì đó là nó nó
lấy ra nó dễ dàng hơn và nó không lặp
lại những cái những cái mà sai lầm của
những cái project khác hoặc là gì đó thì
nó biết nó lấy ở đâu nó xy xuất nhanh
hơn này nọ thì hai cái bả hỏi anh Khoa
làm nhiều anh Khoa cho cái ý kiến của
mình kinh nghiệm của mình biết ơn anh
>> Dạ
>> dạ ok
Để em em trả lời luôn nhỉ. Chứ để nó
quên. [tiếng cười]
Thật chất á thì cái phần này là cái phần
cải tiến ở trong second brand là mình đã
làm rồi mà mình không đưa vô trong đây.
Bởi vì sao? Bởi vì đưa qua nhiều qua
kiến thức là các bạn cũng bị rối và à là
cũng không có hay nên a thực chất á mình
cũng đã đưa rồi chứ không phải là không
có đưa. Ở trong a đây ở trong Wikimedia
à ở trong cái bộ não này nè. Thôi chuyển
qua phần tiếng Việt ha.
Thực chất á là mình kiểu là như thế này
nè.
Nó ngoài cái việc mà các bạn nạp vô
không ár để nạp nè, compile nè, biên
dịch rồi nè thì có thêm một cái gọi là
add là hỏi nè ha. Nghĩa là con wiki con
action của mình nó sẽ sử dụng phần add
này đó nó hỏi nó nó kết nối
sửa chữa chất lượng. Các bạn hiểu ý mình
không? Sửa chữa chất lượng.
À đúng anh nói rất là đúng và chính xác
không phải kiến thức nào đưa vô nó cũng
là nó cũng là hay cả hoặc là nó có thể
thì nó hay thời điểm này nhưng mà nó hay
thời điểm khác. Nếu mà hai dữ liệu ở
trong cái wiki mình cái second brand mà
mình cũng đã chuẩn bị rồi. Nghĩa là nếu
mà hai cái dữ liệu nó đưa vô và nó bị
trùng lắp á thì nó yêu cầu sự quyết định
của mình. Các bạn hiểu ý mình không?
Hiểu ý mình đúng không? Đó thì cái phần
này thì chắc để các bạn sâu đi sâu đi để
các bạn trải nghiệm từ từ chứ bây giờ mà
nhò vô nữa thì nó cũng hơi căng nhưng mà
cái phần này là kho cũng đã bị kho cũng
bị rồi à kho cũng làm rồi đúng không ạ
nó cũng đã một sự trải nghiệm rồi chứ
không phải là là là không được không ạ
nên trong này có những cái gọi là
ngay cả ví dụ một chủ đề mình cũng sẽ
phải auto research nó được không ạ khi
có trùng đắp dữ liệu mình là người quyết
định. Còn cái vấn đề thứ hai mà cái việc
học á theo quan điểm của Kho một cái
chuyện là việc học á thì Kho vẫn đồng
quan điểm cái chuyện đó là mình cùng
mình như nó là cùng học. Nhưng mà mỗi
người có một cái cách học mình á là
người là định hướng là một nè. Cái này
kiểm soát đầu ra là hai được không ạ?
Chứ mình không thể để cho nó làm mà mình
không biết mình đang làm gì sao được.
Đúng không anh? Đúng không anh?
Thì cái đó là một cái vấn đề mà mình
nghĩ đó là mình cũng phải học. Bây giờ
mình học cái cách khác thôi. Thì bây giờ
lúc trước là mình nhảy vô mình viết code
thì bây giờ mình nhảy vô mình quản lý
mình kiểm soát đầu đầu vô đầu ra.
>> Đúng rồi.
>> Mình là project owner. Đúng rồi. Không,
ý ý bảo nói là vậy. Nhưng mà ý nói là ờ
khi mà mình và học mình đã học cho nó
rồi thì kiến thức nó sẽ tiếp thi tiếp
thu ờ từng ngày từng ngày từng ngày thì
những cái kiến thức sau á nó mình sẽ
không có thể nào mình nhớ và đụng một
cái á có thể mình không nảy ra được cái
ý để mình làm. Đụng vô một project đó
mình làm. Thì cái não thứ hai á là nó có
tốc độ truy suất cao hơn, nó có bộ nhớ
này nọ hơn và nó là ai chứ không phải là
mình. nó lại ai mà đúng không? thì nó
phải là người làm chứ mình không có làm.
Mình cũng giống như project owner thôi.
Mình phải biết mình làm gì đó thì khi đó
thì nghĩ là nếu như vậy á thì mình sắp
xếp trong một những cái học kéo nó thì
cái não mình cũng vậy thôi. Nó cũng là
những cái ngăn kéo những cái học rồi nó
nó sắp xếp trí nhớ trong đó thì nó không
biết là mình vô là mình sắp xếp luôn hay
là là nó đã có cái cơ chế nó tự link đến
nhau để mà nó nó
>> nó nó truy xuất dữ liệu không? Anh Khoa
>> chắc hồi nãy anh bảo đi đúng cái phần
gọi là cái phần vắ link là [tiếng cười]
à chắc nếu được thì anh sẽ về anh xem
lại hoặc là em có thể nói đơn giản em em
nói sơ qua tí xíu ha thực [khịt mũi]
chất là ở trong cái bộ não của nó sẽ có
những gọi là cái bắ link để nó kết nối
với nhau nó bắt link á anh nó nó kết nối
với nhau để nó đi truy xuất dữ liệu đầu
tiên là nó vô index để nó tìm cái dữ
liệu trước xong rồi từ cái dữ liệu đó nó
sẽ kết nối cách kết cách kết nối thẳng
cái đến cái nhu cầu của nó đang tìm của
con agent nó sẽ đỡ tốn token hơn so với
nếu mà đọc hết cả một cái cái kho dữ
liệu đó
đúng không ạ? Đó chính là cái mà
second nó làm được cái việc đó.
Ok ha. Rồi còn trao đổi gì nữa không cả
nhà? Ờ để mình cùng có những bạn nào
mình
mình thảo luận nữa đúng không ạ? Có
nhiều bạn thấy nhắn quá trời nhắn luôn
mà không biết bởi vì nãy Kho chưa theo
kiệm Kho vừa thấy cái nó chạy ra mất
tiêu. [tiếng cười]
Cứ trao đổi đi cả nhà mình cũng chỉ là
mình người đi làm thôi mà đâu có vấn đề
gì đâu. Mình thấy hay mình chia sẻ tương
tự mai mốt các bạn anh mấy bạn có gì hay
các bạn chia sẻ cho mình chứ ha.
>> À cái phần này mình chia sẻ thêm chỗ của
cái câu hỏi của Bảo. Thật ra chính mình
cũng đang ứng dụng đó là cái cách lưu
trữ. Nó gần giống với cái việc của lưu
trữ ở trên second friend này nhưng mà
mình đang lưu trữ theo cái gọi là second
friend đúng theo cái mô hình của cái
quyển sách second friend mà cách đây năm
2021 ra đời theo cái mô hình đó luôn nha
cả nhà đó là project rồi active rồi cái
vân vân đó thì khi mà mình ứng dụng cái
đó đó thì thật ra cái mô hình của của
Khoa đang chia sẻ hôm nay rất là hay rồi
mình nói cực kỳ hay luôn à tuy nhiên á
cái này và mình đã ứng dụng yêu cầu cái
con antaravity của mình nó cải thiện lại
một phần thôi chứ nó không phải làm lấy
hết nhưng mà nó sẽ ứng dụng vào trong
cái mô hình của mình à nhúng vào trong
cái second r của mình riêng và mỗi khi
giống như cái câu hỏi của bảo á à khi có
dữ liệu mới khi có cái cái kiến thức mới
thì mình nạp vào. Thật ra là nếu anh em
mà để ý á, mình đã từng chia sẻ là cách
mình đưa dữ liệu từ cái iPhone, từ điện
thoại nha. Từ điện thoại, iPhone. À
những cái ghi chú hay là những cái ghi
âm đặc biệt từ iPhone của mình. Mình
không có dùng Android, mình không rõ là
cách đưa nhưng từ cái ghi chú, từ cái
ghi âm, hai cái đó là cái chính của
mình. Mình sẽ nạp từ điện thoại và sau
đó mình dùng anti gravity nó nạp, nó đổ
dữ liệu về trên máy tính. Và khi nó nạp
về thì lập tức anti gravity nó phải phân
tích được cái nội dung này, phải đưa về
cái học tủ nào, phải đưa về cái ngăn kéo
nào được không ạ? ứng dụng cái mô hình
mà của khoa mình đã yêu cầu nó phân tích
cái cái cái skill của ông Kakabati này
nó sau khi nó phân tích xong thì nó phải
tích lũy lại được vào trong cái mô hình
của mình bao nhiêu phần trăm kiến thức
nó không lấy hết tại vì cái mô hình đó
nó không phù hợp với cái mô hình của
mình kiểu kiểu như vậy. Nghĩa là giống
như cái hồi nãy Khoa có nói một đề cập
nghĩa là không phải kiến thức nào cũng
phù hợp với mình. Có bạn thì học cái đó
nhưng mà chắc gì đã phù hợp với tôi đúng
không? Thì cũng như cái mô hình này nó
lại nạp vào trong cái của mình và khi nó
phân tích xong thì nó nói là cái mô hình
của anh Minh á chỉ phù hợp một phần thôi
cho nên tôi build một phần thôi. Và như
vậy thì khi mà nó lấy cái ghi chú trên
điện thoại mình về, lấy file ghi âm của
mình về á nó nạp vào bên trong cái cái
second frame của mình á vào đúng cái thư
mục project đó thì nó sẽ phân tích nội
dung là nên đưa vào cái nào a nó hay
vậy. Nên đưa vào cái project nào và cái
project nào đang active và cái nào nó
thuộc về phần tài liệu resource nó tự
động đẩy về cái phần đó. Và đến khi cần
á mình chỉ cần là cái gì ạ? Nói với nó
ok hôm nay tao đang cần cái này mày lấy
lại cho tao. Và thậm chí nhá không cần
mình nói luôn như sáng nay mình nhớ mới
cái công việc sáng nay mình đã đang có
làm một cái cái cái cái công việc thì
khi mà mình đưa cái đầu Việt đó vào á
thì lập tức nó chạy ra cái mô hình đó
thì nó nói à cái này là đã có ứng dụng
là cách đây bao lâu rồi mình cũng chẳng
nhớ bao lâu nữa. Cách đây chắc phải vài
tuần lễ hơn rồi là đã từng có cái
project mình tạo ra skill đó.
từng tạo ra cái skill đó nhưng bản thân
mình không nhớ luôn và tự động nó biết
là à hôm nay à đúng rồi cái trường hợp
và chiều mình đang nói về cái làm ờ của
khoa buổi hôm nay làm về poster mình yêu
cầu hãy cho tôi cái poster này và cái
poster này thì có liên quan đến cái nội
dung second r cho tôi là cái ý tưởng và
cũng như cái nội dung này thì lập tức nó
kéo cái ông nội mà tạo skill hình ảnh ở
trong cái antiravity mà trong đó trước
đó mình đã trend nó là không phải chỉ
tạo hình ảnh mà cần phải tạo ra theo cái
mô phỏng đó A BC các kiểu. Thì như vậy
thì lúc này đó là một trong những cái
second r nó nó nó đã được bỏ nằm ngủ yên
ở trong một cái đống nào đó nhưng hôm
nay đến một lúc mà tình cờ nó gặp lại
thì nó sẽ tự động môi đầu nó lên. Thì
nói như vậy để thì ở đây sẽ có rất là
nhiều người vẫn còn mơ hồ nhưng mà tạm
thời là mọi người hình dung là ừ giống
như trường hợp của B anh anh bảo thì
chịu khó. có nghĩa là ngồi tương tác với
AI và sau đó là lấy cái bộ skill của của
khoa hoặc là ở trên mạng thì hiện nay có
rất là nhiều anh anh em khác cũng có
share cái phần này. Sau đó mình đưa cho
con gravity nó học hoặc là nó đọc. Sau
đó mình yêu cầu nó bây giờ tôi tận dụng
cái này như thế nào hay cài đặt như thế
nào rồi mình triển khai mình custom dần
thôi và lúc này mình trải nghiệm thì nó
sẽ làm theo được cái đó và thậm chí nhá
nó sẽ phân biệt được là cái việc này là
cái cái nội dung hồi nãy bảo có đặt câu
hỏi là nó có tốt hay không nó thực sự có
tốt hay không và nó có cần thiết hay
không nó có thể làm được cái việc đó nếu
như đầu tiên mình trend cho nó còn phụ
thuộc vào việc của mình á có nghĩa là
mình phải train cho nó là nó phải hiểu
được là cái này nó có phù hợp với cá
nhân của mình hay không. À hiện nay là
mình đang giống như hôm trước có nhiều
anh em không biết ở đây có một số bạn là
mình đã chia sẻ cái skill về YouTube lên
đúng không ạ? Và YouTube lên thì sau khi
lấy nền tảng của kiến thức của tất cả
các loại kiến thức nước ngoài, nước ta,
nước nào không cần biết thì nó sẽ phân
tích. Sau khi nó phân tích xong thì nó
lấy ba kiến thức gọi là ba kiến thức ẩn
á đại khái như vậy thì nó sẽ phân tích
xong thì nó nói là cái này có phù hợp
với anh Minh hay không. nó sẽ phân tích
và nó trả lời cho mình nó có phù hợp hay
không và tại sao không phù hợp và có nên
tích lũy vào hay không. Nếu ok tôi phải
tôi mới lưu nha. Nó sẽ hỏi như vậy luôn.
Đó là cái cách mà mình đang hiện nay
mình đang ứng dụng như vậy đó là nó phải
hỏi ngược lại mình. Nó phân tích xong
cái script đó và nó đưa ba cái kiến thức
nền tảng mà mà ẩn ở trong đó chứ không
phải là nội dung script không nha. Đó
thì quay lại cái câu chuyện của anh Bảo
thì mình chia sẻ thêm thôi. Ok rồi xin
nhường mic lại cho Khoa và một số anh
chị em khác.
Cả nhà có chia sẻ gì nữa không ạ?
>> Không có thì để Khoa tiến hành Khoa cho
thêm cái phần cài đặt hả? [tiếng cười]
[hắng giọng]
>> Không phải cái cài đặt nó
nó dễ quá
>> nó không có gì nó không có nhiều giá trị
chứ không phải là gì hết cả. Ừ
>> em cũng có làm video ở trong đó mà ở
trên đó để và nói chung là dễ lắm mình
cái quan trọng mình dùng nó như thế nào
thôi. Và giống như anh Minh chia sẻ
quan trọng là mình mình sử dụng nó như
thế nào và nó phù hợp với mình chứ cũng
không nhất thiết là mình không nó làm
mình làm theo. Không có có nhiều có
chuyện đó. Có những cái ví dụ như nó phù
hợp nữa các bạn, nó phù hợp nó quan
trọng. Ví dụ như mình mình thích cô đó
cỡ nào nhưng mà không phù hợp thì không
đến được với nhau đúng không anh? Kiểu
kiểu kiểu dạng vảy hoặc là thấy người ta
ăn sầu riêng ngon quá mình nhảy vô ăn
không được không được. Cái sầu riêng là
không dành cho mình thì [khịt mũi] nó
phải phù hợp nữa và những cái kiến thức
nó áp dụng mà nó linh hồn và nó phụ
thuộc vào sự trải nghiệm của mình nữa.
Thì đó là những cái mà khỏi đúc kết qua
những cái cái cái mình học hỏi được từ
AI.
>> Nhưng mà cái phần trải nghiệm của Khoa
nãy rất là hay nha. Là cái chỗ mà
section cái phần này là hiện nay mình
chưa có là mình sẽ phải bổ sung thêm
mình yêu cầu cái con Asian của mình nó
phải huấn luyện ở chỗ này.
>> Dạ.
Ok. Anh em hiện nay có đặt câu hỏi mình
cứ đặt câu hỏi đi cả nhà. Mình mình biết
là sẽ có rất nhiều người luôn còn vẫn
đang mơ hồ á nhưng mà không biết là đặt
câu hỏi từ đâu luôn đúng không cả nhà?
[tiếng cười]
Còn cách cài đặt cái công cụ đó thì hiện
nay Khoa chắc có lẽ là sẽ để cho một cái
đoạn YouTube ở trên đó rồi chắc có lẽ
mọi người tự xem hả Khoa hả?
>> Dạ ok anh. Em có để trên đó mà.
>> Đúng rồi
>> để trên đó thì
>> có có có anh chị em nào thắc mắc cách
cài đặt không ta? Tại vì ở đây sẽ có rất
là nhiều bạn mình biết một số bạn là
hiện nay đang là người mới về cái lĩnh
vực AI Asian này. Và và
mấy anh nói đặt câu hỏi mà mấy anh không
trả lời.
Đặt câu hỏi mà trả lời ở đâu giờ nhiều
quá rồi. Bật mic được không cả nhà?
>> Bật mic đi. Bật mic.
Như vậy ai qua quá trình đóng góp từng
phiên nói chuyện có cái cái cái phần ở
trong
thôi mình đọc câu hỏi đi Khoa trả lời
luôn ha cho cùng giao đổi đi.
>> Dạ.
>> Ok. Ờ bạn Giang có hỏi là như vậy AI qua
quá trình đóng góp từng phiên nói chuyện
nó biết là cái nào mình thành công, cái
nào mình thất bại nó ghi lại và đưa ra
chính kiến wiki để học. Ủa cái này có
phải câu hỏi không ta?
Hả? gì em? [tiếng cười]
>> Thực ra là em muốn hỏi lại để xem là cái
mà em hiểu là đã đúng với cái mà anh
Khoa đã hướng dẫn hay không. Còn nếu mà
là câu hỏi thì cái mà em tò mò nhất ấy
đấy là anh Khoa thì đã nói rất là nhiều
về cái lý thuyết và cái cách đấy rồi.
Nhưng mà đối với những cái người mới
hoặc là những cái người mà
đang vừa bắt đầu ấy thì mọi người lại
cũng rất là mong anh Khoa sẽ chia sẻ
thêm cho mọi người chính cái trải nghiệm
của anh Khoa ứng dụng của nó hàng ngày
như thế nào thì nó sẽ giúp cho mọi người
hình dung dễ hơn. Thế là em có cái đề
nghị nho nhỏ như thế ạ.
>> Ờ thầy ứng dụng ứng dụng nó đúng không?
Thầy
>> vâng ví dụ như lúc nãy mà anh nói về cái
vấn đề ứng dụng vào pickup là em rất tò
mò bởi vì thực ra trong [tiếng cười]
cái kiến thức nó có rất là nhiều loại
những cái loại kiến thức về mặt logic,
về mặt học thuật ấy thì cái việc mà từ à
hiểu này, biết này, áp dụng này thì mọi
người có thể là hình dung rất là dễ.
Nhưng mà khi mà anh lại đưa ra một cái
ví dụ là về một cái kiến thức về mặt vận
động thì nó khá là khác. Thì khi ra mình
hiểu về kiến thức rồi nhưng anh có nói
với em câu là sau khi mà anh đưa các cái
kiến thức đấy vào có thể là những cái
kiến thức ở trên mạng những cái lý
thuyết mà cái con AI đấy nó lại điều
chỉnh được cho anh về cái mặt kỹ thuật
thì chứng tỏ là phải có một cái dữ liệu
gì đấy nữa khác vào thì là em hơi tò mò
chỗ đó.
>> Ừ. Có muốn có muốn xem không? Có muốn
xem a Khoa Khoa làm như thế nào không?
>> Có chứ ạ. Bởi vì em cũng muốn rất cải
muốn cải thiện xem là tình hình là có
lên được trình không.
>> À ô lên lên trình không à. [tiếng cười]
Chắc là Khoa đụng với Giang là quýnh
chắc không đến không lại quá.
>> Khoa đang mớ. [tiếng cười]
>> Dạ. Kiểu
>> kiểu là như thế này nè. Cái cái cái của
Giang lặp một cái vấn đề là đó là một số
kiến thức á cái một một số kiến thức á
là à hiện tại con ai nó biết được nó
thông qua một cái gọi là cái a cái chữ
thôi đúng không? về nguyên tắc là như
vậy. Cái thứ hai của nó là vision là nó
có thể đọc được nhưng mà đọc cuối cùng
nó quay chuyển qua chữ
đúng không ạ?
Đúng không ạ? Nên làm sao để mình có thể
mình kết nối những cái video làm vào là
thành cái chữ để nó hiểu và xong thường
nó hiểu xong nó sẽ đưa lại cho những cái
kiến thức cho cho mình đúng không?
>> Đúng rồi ạ. Cái vấn đề chỗ đấy đó ạ.
>> Đúng rồi. Thì cái vấn đề nằm chỗ đó là
thì cái cái a
cái về việc đầu tiên đi ha. về việc cái
khó khăn nhất của cái cái ảnh. Cái ảnh
thì bây giờ nó không còn khó khăn nữa.
Những cái con AJ nó có khả năng đọc được
hết, Vision nó đọc được hết. Có khá n là
cái chỗ theo mình hiểu của chỗ Giang nói
á là cái video
đúng không? Thì mình cũng sẽ chia sẻ
à video để mình chuyển mình chuyển về
thuật ngữ, mình chuyển nó thành chữ nó
như thế nào thì có nhiều cách. Nếu mà ở
trên YouTube thì nó đã có sub surprise
rồi thì mình cũng dễ chứ không có vấn đề
gì đâu. Thường á thì ở đây thì kho chia
sẻ nó nó cũng có nhiều cách lắm. Thì ở
đây thì thường nếu mà một cái video á
thì mình thu âm bằng giọng nói đi thì
mình cái cái mà hiện tại mà đang mạnh
nhất và đỡ tốn kém nhất á là kho thường
đẩy lên notebook.
Notebook để chuyển dữ liệu nó thành một
cái gọi là cái cái
sang giọng. giọng để cho nó hiểu được là
một cái vấn đề thứ hai nữa. Thường cái
thứ hai nữa là nếu mà trên YouTube á thì
con khô vẫn thường sử dụng gọi là not
offsent. Offsent có một cái
cóent
có một cái rất là hay mà kho thấy rất là
hay nha. Không biết các bạn ứng dụng
được chưa? Đó là nó có khả năng đọc được
video bằng cái cách mà là ờ đây để cho
coi cho các bạn xem đây. Ừ
mình lên luôn ha. Thì đó là cái cách mà
mình thường mình cũng thường đọc. Mình
lên đó mình đọc nhiều lắm.
Xong đó mình nạp kiến thức nó vào. Ví dụ
như đây đi anh này đi. Anh này đang
nè.
OS nó có một cái option
clip nè. Được không ạ? À thì mình sẽ add
nó vào trong cái đây nè. Nó có đầy đủ nè
các bạn anh chị ha. Nó có đầy đủ nó sẽ
tách ra ở đây. Các bạn mở có thể đỡ đỡ
thêm một cái chế độ đọc nữa. Ừ nè các
bạn nhìn thấy không? Nó chuyển hết tất
cả thành chữ. Và khi mà chữ á thì những
con agent nó xử lý rất là đẹp.
Sự rất là đẹp. Các bạn là vừa mới chia
sẻ với mình một cái con cái con Gemini á
cũng khá là hay. Bây giờ Gemini nó mạnh
đến n mà nó cắt từng cái flam
cắt từng khung hình ra. Cắt từng khung
hình ra để đọc luôn á các bạn và các anh
chị nó cỡ đó luôn. Nhưng mà kho vẫn thấy
một trong những cái là mình dùng thì nếu
mà về kinh nghiệm nếu mà voi á thì con
thấy cái độ ổn định và chính xác nhất
con vẫn đánh giá cao notebook anbook ra
xài rất là ok. Còn nếu mà nhanh gọn lẹ
xài mì ăn liền á thì con thấy cái ứng
dụng của thằng này cũng khá là ok. Cả
nhà tham khảo thử xem sao. Offent nè.
Offent nè.
Nói vậy đó. Rồi xong.
Câu hỏi gì nữa không ngờ? Ok. Ok. Ông
người đẹp.
>> Ừ. Không, có một cái vấn đề là anh đang
bị hiểu nhóm câu hỏi của em. Tức là nếu
như mà việc mà cái việc mà nạp cái kiến
thức vào ấy thì em vẫn hiểu là sẽ nạp
bằng cái cách nào. Bởi vì là kể cả khi
các video thì vẫn có thể dùng để có thể
có tex được. Nhưng cái mà em tò mò là
khi anh nói rằng là nó cũng học như thế
và nó điều chỉnh cái động tác cho anh
thì tức là anh phải cung cấp cái gì thì
nó mới điều chỉnh được đến anh tức là để
hiểu được cái ứng dụng cho bản thân anh
ấy. Hay là cái đấy là em bị nhầm ạ.
>> Không cái nó vẫn đọc được mà đâu có vấn
đề gì đâu. Nó đọc được khung hình ví dụ
như cứu R đi. Cứ Drive đi ha.
>> Ví dụ như là cái khung hình là mình đứng
mình drive cái tư thế của mình ta đọc
từng khung hình được mà.
>> À tức là đọc phần hình ảnh ấy ạ. Đúng
rồi. Bởi vì nếu là mình drive thì mình
không tức là khi mà quay một cái clip mà
mình đang tập chẳng hạn như vậy nhá thì
là mình sẽ không có tiếng nói mà mình
chỉ có phần hình ảnh, phần video chạy
thôi.Ừ
>> thì em ấy đang không hiểu là tại sao là
nó đọc được cái nội dung đấy.
>> Ừ
thì nó nhìn nó vẫn xem được mà.
>> Nó vẫn xem được mà.
Thế như vậy là sau khi mà có kiến thức
rồi này thì anh có một giả sử anh có một
cái clip anh quay cái buổi tập của anh
>> cho anh đưa cái clip đấy vào trong
notebook thì nó không ra được chữ bởi vì
sao là bởi vì là nó không có âm thanh
thế vậy thì làm thế nào để mà cái con
đấy biết
>> ừ cái con cái con đấy biết là cái động
tác sai chỗ nào đúng chỗ nào nó đều chỉ
cho anh ý
>> à thì hồi nãy vừa mới nói đó semin nó
cắt khung hình ra nó cắt cái cái cái cái
từ flame từ flame một ra xong nó chụp
lại nó đối chiếu vô.
>> Ừ.
>> Ờ bây giờ nếu như giả sử em hiểu được về
cái cách thức đấy rồi mà em hỏi cái bước
người khi mà anh triển khai trên máy nó
sẽ như thế nào? Thế anh sẽ đưa vào anh
sẽ hỏi vào con nào và anh sẽ hỏi như thế
nào ấy ạ.
>> Ừ
vẫn đóng ha.
>> Ờ tại vì hôm nay em đưa ra cái chủ đề
này là em thấy là nó rất là thú vị.
>> [tiếng cười]
>> Ờ cái đó hiện tại để để mình gửi cho một
cái để để nếu mà được á thì kết nối cho
mình bởi vì hiện tại cái chủ đề này mà
mình đi sâu quá thì nhiều bạn nó không
có phù hợp.
ở trên hiện tại á có cái có một cái app
mà hôm bữa mình nhớ là cũng về cũng về
một cái trò chơi đó là nó chấm điểm á
chấm điểm mình á dựa vào những cái video
nó gửi cho mình luôn hiện tại đang vẫn
đang làm được cái chuyện đó
thì để có gì khô gửi lại sau nha.
Ok. Còn về một cái ờ còn mình đi sâu về
chủ đề này quá thì nhiều bạn đâu biết
đánh carbon đâu đúng không?
>> À không em hỏi chung cho tất cả các cái
môn bởi vì thực ra trong cái kiến thức
nó cũng chia ra nhiều loại mà thì cái
kiến thức [hắng giọng] mà để cho là việc
mà máy với mình cùng đồng hành để học
tất cả mọi thứ trong cuộc sống ấy thì em
thấy là có thể là với em nó là pick với
anh là pick nhưng với mọi người có thể
là những cái các kỹ năng khác liên quan
đến vận động.
>> Ừ. Ai em cảm ơn em thấy câu hỏi là em sẽ
kết nối với anh sau ạ. Ok rồi cảm ơn
bạn. Dạ
rồi camera nha. Còn câu hỏi gì nữa không
ạ?
À nếu đi sâu đi anh ha. Thôi à nó chia
sẻ với cả nhà là hồi nãy là mình về mình
hơi trễ nói thẳng là chưa ăn gì nên
tạm thời chắc là bởi vì bây giờ thường
là hồi nãy là Facebook có 9:00 à mà bây
giờ nói quá trời nói luôn
>> bây giờ đã 9
>> ờ quéo rồi nên á thì con xin nhường mic
lại cho anh Minh để ảnh a
trao đổi với cả nhà ha
>> tiếp lời À tạm thời. Dạ còn tạm thời thì
ờ chắc là dừng khó dừng tại đây được
không ạ? Rồi.
>> Ok. À cảm ơn a Khoa một cái buổi tối hôm
nay chia sẻ rất là nhiệt tình ha. À cảm
ơn Khoa một lần nữa. Rất là cảm ơn luôn.
Và còn nếu những anh em nào chưa có hiểu
về cái cách cài đặt ứng dụng này á thì
mình sẽ gửi lại cái đường link của khoa.
Cách cài đặt á thì thật sự nó rất là đơn
giản nếu đến thời điểm này nhé. đến thời
điểm này thì tại sao Khoa không triển
khai cái ứng dụng đó mà chỉ nói về cái
mô hình sâu vào bên trong cái cốt lỗi đó
nhưng mà lại không có hướng dẫn cài đặt
thì cũng hiểu đơn giản là tại vì giờ
mình chỉ quăng cái đường link vô thôi
coi nhaở đây mình gửi lại đường link lại
thêm một lần nữa nha cụ Khoa đã gửi cho
mình rồi và hồi nãy mình cứ gửi lên trên
nhóm thì mình xin phép gửi lại một lần
nữa thì bây giờ nó quá đơn giản rồi cho
nên thật ra thì cái này chỉ cần đưa vào
cho
AI agent thôi. AI agent thôi. Nó nó nó
nó yêu cầu nó cài đặt là nó cài thôi. Đó
là cách đơn giản nhất luôn.
À ở đây có một bạn Minh Lê hỏi cách cài
đặt Minh nói tổng quát demo xem. Ờ nó
như thế này nhé. Ok, cảm ơn anh.
Rồi thì bây giờ nhé, bây giờ đây bạn
copy cái đường link này rồi bạn đưa vào
trong cái nền tảng nếu bạn dùng clot hay
là bạn dùng anti gravity hay codex nói
chung là bất cứ cái nền tảng Aent nào.
Sau đó bạn chỉ cần nói là hãy tiến hành
cài đặt à
cài đặt giúp tôi.
Đó thì như vậy nó sẽ tự động nó đưa luôn
cái
cái repoo này. Cái này gọi là cái robo
ha. Mình có thể nó gọi là như vậy. Ừ. Nó
tự động nó cài vào trong máy của mình.
Và ở đây tùy thuộc vào chúng ta mình tạo
ra một cái project nào thôi. Mình tạo ra
một cái thư mục nào trên máy tính và nó
sẽ đẩy về cái thư mục đó trên máy tính
của mình. Thì vì lý do nó quá đơn giản
với bạn bạn Khoa cho nên bạn sẽ không
hướng dẫn. Nhưng trong cái đường link
này đã có link YouTube hướng dẫn của bạn
luôn nha cả nhà. Mọi người vào ở bên
trong đó hồi nãy trong đó có đường link
YouTube thì mọi người có thể xem thêm
cách mà bạn hướng dẫn cài đặt cũng như
cách sử dụng để tiết kiệm thời gian cho
anh em. Rồi thì cái cách đơn giản đó là
như vậy. Còn chi tiết thì mọi người có
thể xem thêm đường link YouTube của bạn
Khoa. Ok. Thì không biết là trong cái
buổi này thì anh Vũ hồi nãy em thấy có
giơ tay thì không biết anh Vũ có cái
phần nào hôm nay anh được gặp lại anh Vũ
rất là vui l.
>> Xin chào. Chào anh Minh. Chắc bạn Khoa
đi rồi cũng không kịp gửi lời cảm ơn
Khoa. Thì nãy giờ mình nghe thật ra mình
cũng bị giống bị bạn bảo là mình cũng
chạy đi giữa đường cho nên mình cũng
không có follow được hết. Hoàn toàn chắc
là sẽ xin cái record để nghe kỹ lại.
Nhưng mà mình thử mình tóm tắt lại cách
hiệu của mình để nhờ Minh xem thử là nó
nó đúng không nha. Thì mình nghĩ cũng
nhiều bạn có thể cũng hơi lơ mơ giống
mình. Tức là nếu mình tức là mình đi từ
cái peny trước là trước khi mình có cái
second brand này thì mình gặp những vấn
đề ví dụ như là hồi nãy mình nghe tức là
bị giữa các session với nhau nó không có
liên thông được về mặt kiến thức đúng
không? Tức là những cái vấn đề mình đã
gặp phải trong cùng một trong có thể
trong cùng một cái reboot hoặc là thậm
chí là nhiều cái project khác nhau. Ví
dụ những con ví dụ mình hay dùng con Jin
nhất thì nó hay bị những cái ẩu ẩu của
nó trong việc là ví dụ nó test bị lỗi
hay là nó lên plan khi triển khai plan
nó không có tuân thủ đúng theo cái plan
đó thì những cái lỗi đó mỗi lần mình sẽ
phải nhắc nó. Thì nếu mình có cái công
cụ này thì
mỗi lần bị như vậy mình sẽ yêu cầu nó
lưu lại đúng không? để lần sau trước khi
mà start project mình yêu cầu là đọc lại
những cái brand cũ về những cái lỗi đó
để lưu ý thêm. Thì cái đầu tiên mình
hiểu là nó tác dụng của nó nó sẽ là sẽ
là như vậy đúng không? Cộng với lại mình
lấy những cái nguồn kiến thức khác mình
đẩy vào thêm thì mình build thành một
cái giống như một cái mạng lưới nonon ở
phía trong. Hồi nãy có thấy cái mô hình
của của chia sẻ như vậy thì mình hiểu là
hai cái tác dụng
>> chính nó là nó là như vậy đúng không?
>> Dạ.
Thì anh mình trả lời giúp đ hai cái câu
đó.
>> Ok. Em nói lại sơ lược cái chỗ này thì
cái phần đó là em cũng nói cũng cũng cái
câu hỏi đầu tiên của anh á thật ra là
anh đang làm anh ứng dụng ở trên cái nền
tảng Germin đúng không ạ? Hồi nãy anh mà
chạy chạy chính bằng agent bằng cái con
con ag native agent của Gemini.
>> À à. Ok. Ờ thì cái này á là do bình
thường chúng ta hay làm việc theo kiểu
là giống như mình đang quen với cái kiểu
làm truyền thống á mọi người. Có nghĩa
là mình đang sử dụng chỉ đơn thuần có
nghĩa là tạo ra một cái luồng chat rồi
sau đó tương tác rồi yêu cầu làm rồi sau
đó kết thúc một luồng chat hoặc là cái
dự án đó nó xảy ra những cái lỗi gì
nhưng chúng ta không hề backup những cái
lỗi đó lại. Kiểu như vậy luôn nha.
em đã từng làm và thấy những cái lỗi đó
hoặc là thấy những cái luồng thông tin
nó trả về rất là hay thì em sẽ bằng cách
là em yêu cầu nó chích xuất lại luôn cái
luồng đó thành một cái file MOD. Sau đó
em đẩy qua Notion bằng cách là kết nối
em cái MCP để lưu trữ lại cái thông tin
đó. Nhưng nhưng như vậy là chưa đủ. Anh
hình dung được cái câu chuyện là hồi nãy
bạn Khoa có chia sẻ là nếu như mình đưa
được những cái luồng đó vào bên trong
cái con ừ cái gọi là là cái second rá
mục đích là nó kết nối và nó tự động nó
truy xuất được cái thông tin đó và nó
như cái bộ não thứ hai của mình để chị ạ
khi gặp lại cái tình huống đó thì lập
tức nó biết rằng à ở đây là bạn đã từng
gặp cái chuyện này rồi, đã từng có cái
vấn đề với cái lỗi giống tương tự như
vậy rồi thì bạn không nhất thiết bạn
phải làm cái tình huống nó giống vậy nữa
đâu. Đó và thông thường chúng ta cứ làm
theo thói quen là chúng ta cứ chat rồi
xử lý dự án A B C kiểu và tạo ra những
cái project. Mặc dù mình nghe thì mình
nói là mình tạo rất là nhiều project
ret, tạo rất là nhiều dự án nhưng những
cái thông tin mà chúng ta tạo trong
những cái luồng chat đó nó cực kỳ quý
giá, cực kỳ chất lượng. Và chính bản
thân em cũng hay nói với các bạn mà em
cũng đang có hướng dẫn á thì em luôn
luôn nói là mọi người nên đọc kỹ cái
thông tin trả về của AI AEN trong tất cả
những cái luồng chat đó. Vì thông tin đó
rất là quý, thông tin rất đó nó nó thật
sự là quý giá từ kể cả cái câu trả về
thông báo lỗi hay là thông tin trả lời
trả lời thành công. Nhưng mà mọi người
đang bị vướng là mình không lưu trữ lại
cái đó và chính bản thân em cũng bị. Đó
bằng cách là như hồi nãy bạn Khoa làm là
mình sẽ lưu lại tất cả những cái section
nó bao gồm thất bại và thành công để lần
sau nó sẽ biết và nó chỉ cần gặp lại
tình huống nó ok tôi bóc luôn cái này
thì như vậy nó sẽ nhanh chóng hơn đỡ cõi
cuối cùng là tiết kiệm cot tiết kiệm
token mà thôi đó và tiết kiệm thời gian
thì cái đó là cái tình huống thứ nhất
cái tình huống thứ hai á là cái câu hỏi
thứ hai của anh anh Vũ á à hình như là
mình đưa kiến thức mới vào đúng không
anh Vũ hả?
>> Đúng rồi. Nãy mình thấy là bạn lấy những
cái kiến thức mới bạn đưa vào như th một
file m down.
>> Dạ. Rồi SS nó vào gọi cái skill là
engage gì đó nó
đúng rồi dạ đúng rồi. Thì cái này là
nguyên cái bộ skill của bạn đã đóng gói
á là cái đó là theo cái của ông Kati á.
Thì LM Wiki này do bạn đang chỉnh sửa
lại thì nó sẽ sử dụng những cái câu lệnh
giống như hồi nãy là anh thấy đó là cái
chỉ cần gõ cái câu lệnh gọi cái skill đó
lên thì nó lập tức nó sẽ đi đọc à cái
cái cái kiến thức mới đó và nó ghi vào
bên trong cái não để lần sau mà có thì
nó sẽ đọc lấy ra thôi và ứng dụng. Và
cái đó bạn có link với cái notion cái
obsidian
để mình đọc được cái nội dung bên trong
đó. Thay vì mình đứng từ bên trong cái
nền tảng một là nó có những cái điểm hạn
chế. Ví dụ như mình đứng từ trong
Gravity bản C gọi là CLI á hay là C gọi
là CLI á thì cái đó là giao diện comment
nó sẽ rất là khó đọc nội dung. Mình có
thể làm việc xử lý rất là nhanh nhưng
giao diện
>> ừ
>> đó là giao diện dòng lệnh. Đó là cái thứ
nhất. Cái thứ hai nữa là đối với những
cái agent khác nó đôi khi nó không đọc
được cái nội dung cái đoạn test ở bên
trong à của file MCO thì lúc này mình sẽ
nhờ cái Obsidian đọc cái nội dung test
đó. Đọc cái nội dung đó. Nhưng quan
trọng là cái gì ạ? Tất cả những cái kiến
thức mới anh nạp vào trong cái frame đó
thì quan trọng là gì? Đó là wikilink hay
nãy là back link mà bạn Khoa có nói nó
sẽ back link cái phần đó lại và chúng ta
nó sẽ link với nhau. Và cái chỗ này em
sẽ diễn giải thêm để cho anh Vũ cũng như
mọi người hình dung thêm.
Nó là như một cái mạng
mạng mạng mạng lưới mà gọi là cái dây
neuron thần kinh của chúng ta.
>> Thì ví dụ nhá, em nói ví dụ thôi. Khoa
biết đến em, em biết đến anh Vũ và anh
Vũ biết đến anh Tú. Như vậy đây là một
cái vòng tròn kết nối. Tuy nhiên, tuy
nhiên là sao ạ? Chúng ta chỉ biết là
biết thông qua từng người một. Thì như
vậy thì cái anh Obsidian này anh làm cái
chức năng đó anảnh sẽ tạo ra một cái
mạng lưới à em biết bạn Giang, biết anh
Vũ rồi từ anh Vũ lại biết bạn Bảo, biết
bạn Khoa. Thì đó là cái trong cái não
mình đang nhớ như vậy nhưng không thể
nào chúng ta nhớ hết được trong những
cái mối liên hệ khác. Ví dụ anh Vũ còn
biết ra những cái người khác nhưng mà
nguyên một cái vòng trồng kết nối rớn
thì mình không thể nào. Và như vậy thì
Obsidian nó sẽ làm được cái việc đó là
nó rá view lại cái việc đó. Nhờ như vậy
thì AI sẽ đọc được dữ liệu rất nhanh tại
vì nó toàn là Wikilink với lại MDO. Mà
dữ liệu này thì ai đọc cực nhanh luôn,
xử lý cực kỳ nhanh luôn, không tốn cota
cũng như là kiểu như là là đốt token đó.
Cho nên tại sao phải dùng tới cái công
cụ Obsidian để hiển thị là RAP view cũng
như là hiển thị nội dung lên để xem lại
cho nó nhanh. Đó là mấu chốt thôi chứ
còn thực ra người mình không có đọc cách
nào nổi cái RAP view đó đâu ha. Rồi thì
cái phần đó em chia sẻ thêm thôi.
>> Rồi thì trong thêm một câu hỏi nãy thì
vì nó hơi tò mò chút tức là như vậy mình
sẽ thay đổi cái thói quen của mình tại
th quen của mình hiện tại á là mình sẽ
cố gắng mình duy trì một cái luồng chat
dài để mình kế thừa được những cái cái
thông tin trước đó. Ví dụ liên quan mình
sửa một cái trang lên base thì mình sẽ
sẽ sửa này ở trên sau đó mình sửa tiếp.
Thì nếu mình mình mở một cái đoạn chat
mới thì thường á hồi trước mình có một
cái trong trong IDE mình có kỹ thuật là
mình xuất cái cái nội dung cái cái file
MD của conversation ra xong mình quăng
cái cái link của file MD đó vào cho nó
đọc cho cái cửa sổ mới á nó sẽ đọc lại
nguyên cái cái cái conversation đó luôn.
>> Thì nó cũng nó cũng thường kể được một
phần nhưng mà nhưng mà nhưng mà nó cũng
sẽ không không bằng được ngay trên cái
cửa sổ đó. Nhưng mà nếu mình ghi trề dài
thì sẽ bị cái vấn đề nãy nói là về token
>> về cái cái cửa sổ context Windows.
>> Dạ đúng rồi.
>> Thì hồi nãy mình tất nhiên mình cũng tìm
hiểu là 1 triệu là cái lý lý thuyết
thôi. Thì ờ bạn nãy mình có nghe lá là
khoảng cỡ vài vài trăm ngàn là mình nên
nên
>> 600 700.000
>> thì cái cái mình đang hỏi là cái công cụ
gì để mình mình đo lường được là hiện
tại cái cửa sổ đó nó đến nó đến bao
nhiêu tokening.
Hiện nay khi mà dùng trên antiraity thì
chính bản thân em cũng chưa đo được cái
việc đó nha. Em dùng cái con lot để em
có thể đo được, đo lường được, em thấy
được cái lượng toen nó tiêu hao. Nhưng
mà antiravity thì có lẽ là mình phải tìm
hiểu thôi đúng không? Mình thấy bắt đầu
nó ngáo ngáo ngáo là nghi rồi đúng
không?
>> Đúng. Còn em dùng cái clot thì em có
thấy nó hiện được cái số lượng toen nó
đốt.
>> Ừ.
>> Dạ. À nhưng mà em bổ sung thêm cái chỗ
này. Thông thường á với em á hiện nay em
đang sử dụng cái mô hình mà giống như
thay vì cuối ngày nha. đến cái đoạn cuối
ngày. Vì hồi nãy em có nói là em ứng
dụng cái cái này thật ra anh chị chỉ cần
lên Asian và mình yêu cầu nó thôi. Nghĩa
là tìm cái bộ mà skill của ông Kati này
hay là skill tương tự của bạn Khoa vừa
chia sẻ tích hợp vào trong cái hệ thống
của mình thì của em đang làm như vậy. Và
đến cuối ngày nhá, đến cuối ngày, đến
cuối ngày tất cả những cái đầu việc mà
em đang làm trong cái luồng chat này hay
là ở trong tất cả những luồng chat khác
nó sự tự động nó đi tổng hợp lại tự động
nhé. Nó có một cái câu lệnh mà em đã làm
và em chỉ cần là cái gì ạ?
>> Cái câu lệnh thi của bên kia là khác.
Thí dụ như cụ khoa là khác câu lệnh của
em là ba
cái project đó là cái của em là ba và
kết thúc là chữ n là kết thúc theo ngày.
Thế thôi và tự động sau khi em gõi cái
câu lệnh là B thì lập tức nó sẽ đi tổng
hợp tất cả dữ liệu mà nó đang nằm ở trên
tất cả các luồng chat. Tất cả luồng chat
luôn nhé. Trong một ngày, trong một ngày
là xem em đã làm được những gì. lập tức
nó lưu lại cái thông tin đó, nó bó lại
và nó đưa vào trong cái một cái thư mục
giống như nãy đầu tiên Bảo có hỏi một
cái đó là đưa vào đâu thì nó sẽ đưa vào
một cái thư mục mà sắp xếp theo gọi là
cái second r theo cái quyển sách mà của
ờ em không nhớ chính xác quyển sách đó
tên gì cách đây đó hồi nãy em có nói thì
lập tức nó đưa vào cái cái cái thư mục
đó và ngày hôm sau ngày hôm sau buổi
sáng em chỉ là cái gì ạ đánh cái chữ là
ba start thì lập tức nó sẽ kéo cái lượng
dữ liệu đó lên nó đọc lạ Thì khi nó đọc
lại là nó biết cái dự án nào của em đang
gian dở, chưa làm hoàn tất. Nó lại nhắc
em, ê mày còn đang vướng kìa, mày còn
đang nợ kìa. Thật ra em đi học một cái
khóa bên kia đang đăng ký là sáu buổi,
em học mới được có hai buổi. Em còn nợ
môn kiểu kiểu như vậy đi và em mới có
nạp dữ liệu cho nó hai buổi và em nói em
phải trả bài cho cái môn này. Nhưng mà
cứ mỗi ngày tổng kết là em chưa khai báo
với nó luôn. Tao chưa hoàn tất. Tao chưa
hoàn tất. Và thế là nó kéo dài cho em là
mày chưa hoàn tất và mày đã bị hóa hạn.
nó báo em suốt luôn. Kiểu kiểu như vậy
nha. Và cứ mỗi ngày như vậy thì anh hình
dung là cái câu chuyện là chúng ta có
bao nhiêu luồng chat không cần biết. Thì
lúc này anh kéo được cái skill đó về anh
tích hợp vào bên trong hệ thống của anh
á thì lúc này nó rất là đỡ cho anh ở
trong những cái việc mà luồng chat anh
phải đóng gói thành nguyên một cái hệ
thống file MC down.
>> Ừ.
>> Dạ.
>> Còn thì như vậy là nó nếu mà kết hợp với
cái của Khoa của Khoa cũng đã có một cái
tương tự rồi đúng không? Tức là cũng có
cú
>> Đúng rồi. Anh kéo cái đó về cũng được.
Dạ anh anh anh đưa về nhưng mà dĩ nhiên
mình phải ờ một là mình sử dụng luôn để
mình hiểu được cái cách dùng sau đó là
có thể là anh custom lại dần
>> tùy. Dạ.
>> Ờ nhân tiền hỏi gì tại mình thấy trong
NT 2.0 của A Manager nó cũng có một cái
lệnh lên á thì mình thấy nó cũng giống
như cũng đút kết cả một cái phiên đó
những vấn đề đúng không? Thì nó cũng có
có vẻ cũng tương tự.
À cái này thì chắc có lẽ ở đây có bạn
Yến là bạn một số bạn cũng đang là em
đang hướng dẫn thì cái lệnh lên này với
em mà nói thật sự nó rất là quan trọng
và cứ mỗi buổi chiều em sẽ cho nó học em
sẽ cho nó đọc lại một lần ở trong tất cả
các luồng chat thì lệnh lên này hiểu cơ
bản là đúng là như anh Vũ vừa nói nó
chính là cái phần đút rút kinh nghiệm ở
trong cái quá trình mà mình sử dụng à
mình giao tiếp hiểu cơ bản là như vậy đi
ha chỉ cần mình đánh một cái lệnh lên
thôi mình thậm chí luôn em làm việc rất
là nhiều em chat với nó A BC gì không em
không cần biết. Mọi người mới sử dụng
thì mình còn tìm hiểu cơ bản nhưng còn
nếu mà mình làm nhiều rồi á thì mình cứ
đánh một cái câu lệnh là xệt lên thì tự
động cái đó nó sẽ đút rút ra à những cái
này nó có cái gì hay à kinh nghiệm gì là
trong này phần nào phần nào vân vân thì
nó sẽ ghi vào đâu ạ nó ghi vào một cái
file gọi là asent.md hoặc là nó ghi vào
trong cái file gọi là germin.md ở đây
tùy theo cái nội